foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
there's music going in the background i
think is it too loud let me check it let
me check
you check it let me check oh that's
right look that's why because i was
sitting there going are you high why are
you bringing your like headphones but i
totally forgot about the
about the thing how is it that's not
loud enough it's not loud enough
are you sure i don't hear anything okay
well well it takes a
it starts out like quiet so just
a little bit more okay yeah because it
starts fades in very slowly
it fades okay can you hear it now
verizon that's probably good that's
probably good
yeah because i feel like that was like
right around minus minus
19 decibels something like that was uh
right about where it was because
i got a jenny are you already drunk i
wish
i've got zach in here no i just started
see that's the proof
well i don't know if that's proof
because i could have drank here
trevor
karen rob everybody's here yeah and then
we got
more than that
dj maniac says i have acquired ice ice
cream
we're just getting this started i could
eat ice cream i can't you know
it's good to have you guys back on a
wednesday yeah it's
people might think there's a whole other
kind of show
i got some spiced rum it's pretty good
that's right
you did buy ramen the last time you were
there well i got
normally what i get but i got it spiced
wrong
and it's just like bacardi i think it is
bacardi yeah
or captain mortgage or something like
that it just tastes like good
zack says music is also a tad louder
than you guys so i turned it down a
little bit
i mean we can't hear it so let me try it
again like i can hear it but it's real i
don't know what the song is too
it's just like a a general like three
hour vaporwave
yeah mix yeah down bring it down just a
tab
bring it down okay yeah a little bit
more
a little bit more okay a little bit more
a little bit more women you know what
it's not going down
oh i see that's no i know what it is i
had to wait for it to yeah
behind because you're about five okay
bring it up a little bit high
delay yeah it's about a five second
delay
between here and there
all right a little bit more up or down
up
more a little bit more than that that's
where it was before
we're just getting everything started
getting everything situated
yeah zach said he's on the keto diet
yeah i'm not doing keto but i am doing
um that thing where they like
intermittent fasting where you only
there's like an only
uh eight-hour window where you can eat
like between 11am and 7pm and then
you're not allowed to eat outside of
those
hours like every day so i've been doing
that keto long term will [ __ ] you up you
can lose weight it will yeah but
you can do it short term yeah i mean um
everybody that
um all those fitness guys that know that
went on it just pure
meat boy they say it's hard to stick to
it
you feel you start sweating out really
greasy
[ __ ] sweat and uh they say you know
going to the bathroom's a nightmare oh
yeah i say after are we talking about
poop already this early on the show
they say take the duck that just [ __ ]
you up
okay it's just big greasy shits i don't
know
that doesn't sound like a fun time i
gotta say
yeah i'm telling [ __ ] khan about
slime i settled i send him a mexican
mexican joke he's laughing
a mexican joke yeah mexican he's
laughing he thinks that's just funny
khan is from tijuana i just told him
that we were streaming
yeah dj maniac says if it's served in a
mason jar
is it a triple i'm not even really sure
how many drinks is that what's that that
in your
giant pickle jar it's got it i'm gonna
show you guys
the meme that i sent that i sent him
what is it
it's a dude in the sombrero all right
and it says the mexican word of the day
body wash and then the example
biden was on tv but nobody watched him
[Laughter]
nobody bought get it nobody watched it i
get it it's just not funny
and that was because they were they were
joking that he only got 30 000 viewers
but it may not be true no it doesn't but
you know
whatever if it makes you feel no better
hey man it's mimology they're gonna meme
warfare
me more said he's buying some stuff
i guess uh i guess he's out shopping
he's he's not home but he's going to be
home in a few minutes
well yeah he can't watch what he can't
watch while he's driving that would be
irresponsible
yeah the um doing that pure
keto is pretty [ __ ] rough all right
so let's see how many people we got in
here now
all right we got 30 in there now we're
going to talk about some [ __ ] zach says
not just pure meat though it's also
uh like nut butters and stuff like that
okay yeah guys that i was talking about
they were called
what was the name of that channel it's
on youtube they went through that whole
thing
i think it's called buff dudes it's like
a comedy
it's like a comedy show it's got two
guys in there they're both [ __ ]
muscle heads they do all kinds of
crazy [ __ ] fitness stunts and try
they try all these diets and rate them
it's called buff dudes was the name of
it and they went on one of those pure
meat keto diets i think they were on it
for about a month they say
by the time they got it's either a month
or two by the time they got to the end
of the challenge
they were [ __ ] dying to come off of
that they had absolutely no carbs
just fat and protein
see i don't think i could do that i mean
i don't mind
having like a little bit of carbs yeah
it's better not to have a lot of carbs
because then it gives me like a stomach
ache anyway they got very lean
lost a lot of weight um they were still
able to work out they got very vascular
i think they you're so vascular yeah
they got real veiny
looking they looked real dry they looked
good
like jerky kinda no i mean well that's
kind of a terminology that bodybuilders
use
if you're on certain
performance-enhancing drugs or if you
drink a lot of water
you can kind of bulk up with some water
weight and it kind of
i think probably an average person
wouldn't notice it but bodybuilders look
at each other kind of like the way other
people look at a side of beef or
something
when they if you get a little too wet or
a little
too hydrated you lose a lot of muscle
definition
like you you don't get that granular
look on the muscle and [ __ ]
they're they're they're they constantly
judging each other like they're in some
kind of competition
so the standards are [ __ ] insane but
that's just the way those dudes are you
know
so um
eating that all meat diet you will get
pretty
pretty cut looking but uh they just say
it feels terrible they say go in the
bathroom it was a [ __ ] nightmare
too they just say it's terrible see it's
like
why are you making me picture that over
and over they said
it was the worst big muscular dude he
probably is like his arms are too big to
wipe his butt and he's just like you
know
they're not that big they're not that
big they're they're i know i'm just yeah
but they're they're just it's called
exaggeration
they just say it's [ __ ] really bad
you know they were just dying to come
off of it they wanted to get on a more
regular but they look real dry they did
[ __ ] kind of lose a lot of water
weight they
they got a good definition but it they
just said it was just miserable
and um they felt energetic but they just
said it was a weird kind of
energy it didn't feel normal you know
you have to go back and watch the
episode i don't remember all the details
they just didn't like how it felt
they want you got to have some carbs in
there yeah you were telling me about
that it's
like i said it's good for weight loss
but you know
pretty much any decent doctor would tell
you you know you can do it short term
um and it will you know hurt you too
much and you will lose weight but you
can't do that like forever
yeah well these dudes didn't hardly
start off with any fat anyway yeah
they're kind of bodybuilding you do need
a little bit of carbs but it is better
to
you know keep the carbs to a minimum
though
i think what yeah i don't know you don't
know
yeah no i'm just saying yeah
oh i don't know i thought i don't know i
never know when you're done talking i
was done talking no it's like um
no what you were saying um about
uh dudes looking at other dudes like
they were a side of beef or whatever
i was like you guys for for any of you
guys that watch my book review channel
this might be a couple weeks before this
goes up
but speaking of cannibalism uh yeah i'm
reading this [ __ ] right here
this is [ __ ] up this is very [ __ ] up
so uh yeah i'll be reviewing this in a
cup it's you know cannibalism that's all
i'm gonna say
yeah there's a lot of cannibals [ __ ] out
of this and it's like okay
it's legal cannibalism is legal in this
book dj says that the dj maniacs is half
my pro wrestler friends are either keto
or vegan um i've seen a lot of the
i've seen a lot of the evidence you know
that's been that guys have you know done
you know
they'll do all videos on it they'll do
blood work and they'll
keep track and there's a lot of fake
fitness out there just like there used
to be fake [ __ ] kung fu
fake martial arts there's fake fitness
too fake natty's
guys saying he's all natural [ __ ] no
enhancements that dudes on sarms or
[ __ ] steroids you know
um the [ __ ]
dieting man no extreme kind of diet is
good for you
just sorry none of those extreme diets
are good
i wouldn't do keto not pure keto i'd
maybe bump up protein intake
and maybe but then eat some carbs
well i think that's but don't don't do
it purely that's kind of the most
sustainable diet
really it's just you know you need
grains you need um you know you need
meat you need vegetables and fruit and
stuff
keep carbs to a minimum and sugars to a
minimum and you can do that forever and
you'll probably be like
you know and you know something else you
got to think about
is that the bodybuilders of today are
not like the bodybuilders of say like
arnold schwarzenegger's era
back in this golden era of you know the
70s and 67
they're not the same i mean by today's
standards arnold would be considered
kind of small
which is insane if you ask me because
these guys
they uh they can get their hands on
[ __ ] drugs and chemicals that just
[ __ ] make them huge
and they're also you know they have good
genetics too it's it's everything but
but those mr olympias started in the 90s
and the
2000s they were just got too [ __ ] big
i mean they didn't
the aesthetics weren't there they didn't
look good if you asked me the aesthetics
were not there i mean i
respected that that's what they wanted
but i kind of like classic physique you
know
it's kind of like what arnold and the
old classics from the 70s to me that
looked good but they would consider that
to be easy to do nowadays
um but it's just the evolution of that
it's not they're going to call it a
sport it's not a sport there's no scores
it's judgment
they're judging it's what the judges
want well it's an aesthetic it's a
[ __ ] beauty contest
it is it's a male beauty it's just
really really funny that they don't call
it that it's just i don't want to say
that
it's just kind of like the way that you
know perfume is perfume but if it's for
a man it's supposed to be called cologne
yeah
it's all the same olympia
is [ __ ] an extension of mr universe
which is that's the male version of mrs
universe you know and [ __ ] this is a
[ __ ]
it's a beauty pageant yeah obviously
i'll beauty pageant how funny would it
be if they made them like wear evening
gowns and walk in heights
i'd watch it then see how that works
out for you why is why is my head so big
i don't know so i don't know
it's genetics i just kind of like well i
guess because i sweat my bangs over here
because i kept like [ __ ] with him and
i couldn't get him to do right and i was
just like you know what [ __ ] it i'm just
gonna like put him like that but then it
makes my [ __ ] head look enormous
maybe it's just my uh
it was just my imagination because i'm
so used to having bangs
that when i don't have bangs i'm always
like look how [ __ ] giant my head is
oh my god
they're talking about lou ferrigno yeah
lou lou was actually bigger and taller
than arnold
uh eventually he filled that body out
more i he i think he was
he was bigger he and i think he looked
probably a little bit better than arnold
a certain way but let's let's be honest
bodybuilding is a [ __ ] beauty pageant
for men
a lot of it has to do with charisma
and personality and basically arnold was
the [ __ ] king but we're talking about
the old arnold of the 70s and 80s
you know um if you go and see
like pumping iron you can watch that for
free on youtube at least you know it's
free for me i i i have that youtube i
think it might be on tubey as well
maybe you see what arnold was like
before he was a movie star and before he
got into [ __ ] politics
so much pot smoking he was a lot cooler
[Laughter]
he was he was a lot cooler he's not the
way a lot of people
think he is he's not a serious dude he's
a [ __ ] joker
yeah he's a [ __ ] troll all right he
came out with a damn
whole video training about vegan diet
and vegan bodybuilding
and he'd gone about how he went totally
vegan
he [ __ ] lies he's lying he's lying
people that know i'm saying he's alive
that you don't know who [ __ ] arnold
is
arnold will [ __ ] lie and pull your
leg and do and
and do whatever this goes all the way
back to eugene sandow one of the
original
fathers of bodybuilding he lied a lot
too
okay it's show business just the other
day
arnold was talking [ __ ] and on camera
opened up his refrigerator to get
something and you can see in the
refrigerator there's nothing but [ __ ]
meat last year it was that's not mine oh
yeah
okay like when cops find drugs in your
car yeah and then
then he [ __ ] came out just because
look
he's a he's an ex-republican he was the
republican governor of california
he's friends with all these hollywood
[ __ ] flunkies
and over time california just kind of
affected him and
he's full of [ __ ] all right he's full of
[ __ ] whatever is popular that's what
arnie's gonna tell you
okay he was said that he was gonna
[ __ ]
drive nothing but his tesla nothing but
his electric cars
that [ __ ] has got a bulgari he's got a
[ __ ] bugatti veyron
and drives it in bumper-to-bumper la
traffic
you know guys who know him just saw him
like and they were talking about it just
a couple weeks later
yeah yeah they were making fun of him
he's driving that bugatti around if you
[ __ ] flora bugatti will empty that
gas tank in about 10 minutes
all right he's got a [ __ ] he's got
all kinds of [ __ ]
[ __ ] owns tanks he owns tanks
well yeah
okay because why wouldn't you yeah he's
got a bunch of houses and [ __ ]
don't listen to [ __ ] arnie's full of
[ __ ] he's he's a troll
well yeah he's a good guy he's just he's
going to tell you whatever is
cool to tell you at the time zack said
he'd love to see arnie in a straight up
dramatic role he was
he was in uh maggie in that zombie movie
yeah it's good he played he was actually
really good in that i was supposed to
say
the one where he played that that guy
who's lost his family in the air
in the air crash yeah yeah yeah he
played a villain in that one yeah
that was actually really good i liked
maggie better but that was good too
in in maggie he just played a dude whose
spoiler alert whose uh daughter turns
into a zombie or she's going to turn it
off yeah
right yeah it's a good zombie and he's
like you know having like a [ __ ]
crisis about it because he knows he's
gonna have to kill her and all this
other kind of stuff not an action movie
it's more like a stage play
yeah a lot of good acting in it to drama
um
i'm a fan of arnold um especially his
classic movies
uh do i believe everything arnold says
[ __ ] no you got to know who he is man
you guys
you find out who he is but listen to
guys like
who grew up with him in the [ __ ]
bodybuilding scene back in the day
like uh leroy colbert or leroy colbert
that was his [ __ ] body
he came up with him in gold's gym he was
the first black bodybuilder to be on
[ __ ] muscle mags [ __ ] joe weeder
almost adopted him like a son that was
[ __ ] leroy and there's leroy's entire
[ __ ] body of work is on youtube
before he died he died a couple years
back from a fall he lost his foot when
he was
a kid in a motorcycle wreck they put it
back on
but he couldn't do a posing routine and
he was kind of retired from bodybuilding
but he
never did steroids evidently had a
[ __ ] great physique
and uh he handled a lot of joe readers
business and
he uh owned a little chain of like
vitamin supplement stores
uh for bodybuilders that's what he did
for a long time leroy knows a lot about
natural bodybuilding but he'll tell you
the way arnold really was he even posted
recorded conversations he was having
with arnold at parties and [ __ ]
all right and leroy was just a motor
mouth and
they're young you know leroy's just
motor mouth and they're
they're they're arnold's [ __ ] with
him like i can't get a word in edgewise
you never shut up just [ __ ] like it's
just [ __ ] funny
and arnold and you know
he said arnold showed up and
if you see if you see pumping iron
you'll see arnold's [ __ ]
he's an austrian [ __ ] soldier he was
a tanker just moved the united states
with [ __ ]
his buddy from sardinia what was his
name
he just died recently he was also in
conan
um i can't remember his name look at me
i don't know
yeah i can't remember his name he was
also a mystery universe he was like in
the under 200. that was like
arnold's mini me all right uh franco
franco colombo
franco was arnold's one of arnold's best
friends
and franco they moved they moved to the
united states together
arnold shows up he's kind of stuck up
talking big
he was telling everybody he was going to
be a big hollywood movie star
and they just thought he was full of
[ __ ] all right they just thought he was
full of [ __ ]
well because a lot of people say [ __ ]
like that yeah it turns out
99 of the time it doesn't work out right
turns out
yeah not only did he conquer hollywood
he ended up becoming a governor in new
york
and then he was like i told you so yeah
but
what he and franco does run around and
[ __ ] build i can't see
concrete walls they were they were they
were in a little construction business
together
yeah yeah like a real construction
business or
they would build concrete walls oh okay
they built yeah they worked out and
they worked out and then they'd go and
build walls build
concrete walls and put up chain-link
fence and do just do [ __ ] like that
okay you're like contractors i gotcha
but um
you haven't showed anybody your shirt
yeah that's an arnold right there
and look at that well you gotta stand up
so you can see the bottom of it
and then like shown in the back yeah see
she got that for me i got that for him
yes
i got him out in the flock of seagulls
shirt
my god so like what are we going to talk
about man
you know we're already looking forward
to that
[Laughter]
i just did too late well one of the
things i wanted to talk about
was i wanted to talk about some new
stuff that came out about a um
about a i guess you could call it like
probably one of the most credible
credible
ufo oh this is what you're really of all
times
which is the omoamoa [ __ ] incident
and they're talking there's this uh
harvard scientist i forgot his name i
was just listening to him but
um abby loeb yeah yeah abby loeb i've
i've heard that dude's name before right
you can go on youtube and see
uh that he posted something on a show
called event horizon just a couple days
ago a couple days back
they're just doing further analysis of
this object
that came into the solar system it came
from outside the solar system it was the
first
confirmed sighting of something that was
from outside our solar system
it came in at a pretty high rate of
speed
went into the inner [ __ ] planets i
think it was in between
earth and [ __ ] earth and the sun
and then the sun's gravity got it bent
its course a little bit
once it passed the earth once it passed
the sun it accelerated away
a smooth acceleration it didn't it
wasn't a comet
they didn't see any outgassing or
anything from the sun hitting on it
it was just a strange object it was
small
and it was very bright and it seemed to
be tumbling it was either
cigar shape pancake shape
um they don't they still don't know what
it was alien spacecraft
well this obvious thinking that there is
a possibility he's not saying that it is
but he says there's a possibility
that that might have been a solar sail
or a probe with a solar sail
because said he said that the the
likelihood
of it coming in from that angle and then
going into the inner planets
says man that's almost in in galactic
terms that's a direct hit
almost like it was done on purpose
yeah no one's seen anything since that
or after
and where are the other ones there's
only one and it
it it's just it's just a mystery you
know
but that's the closest thing to like a
[ __ ] scientifically
confirmed it was an unidentified object
and it accelerated away now that's going
to happen you know what i mean that's
going to happen when you sling something
around a gravitational field
yeah but evidently it accelerated
faster than it should have
and they didn't see what was called
outgassing you know because when you
have sun's rays hitting on something
like
say maybe it's solid hydrogen frozen
hydrogen
it can evaporate on that side of it
which
actually causes thrust
get up yeah but when that happens you
see a tail it becomes a comet
and there was no tail it must maybe it
was some kind of gas that's invisible
but they did all kind he's they've done
all kinds of calculations they said
in order to account for that additional
acceleration
had it been hydrogen or some other gas
it would have to lose like 10 percent of
its mass and it didn't
because it would have to burn it up as
fuel
you know yeah it could be something to
it so they were just saying he
obvious thinking that there's something
to it you know
they just thought it was odd said maybe
it's some kind of a probe
i did like that he kind of i don't know
if i'd go so far to say he called
[ __ ] on the drake equation but he
did kind of say
that because this is something i always
said about that it seems like it's
making a lot of assumptions it's like if
they were intelligent you know it
they're basically saying if there was
intelligent life in the universe they
would have visited us by now
um [ __ ] and yeah and he was kind of
calm [ __ ] and he's like why
because we've said that too it's like
sometimes if if aliens were so far ahead
of us
like i feel like they wouldn't even
[ __ ] bother yeah why would they
bother
yeah it'd be like hey i'm gonna cruise
down and look at that [ __ ] ant hill
yeah no obvious got it more correct
if you're a space faring civilization
billions of years in advance of us
you're probably going to be some kind of
a living machine to begin with
you're not going to be biological
problems uh you're also going to be very
ancient you've seen everything we have
to assume that we're not special
so there must be lots of planets like us
yeah and lots of places like you know
lots of civilizations like ours
and they've probably seen lots of them
come and go over time
and they're just not too interested in
them i mean i wouldn't be
yeah well if you go out to your backyard
you see a bunch of bugs
do you stop and like oh wow and like
contemplate their whole entire like
ecosystem or anything like that yeah i
wonder what this ant hill's doing here
you know
wow maybe i should communicate with
these ads
[Laughter]
you know maybe i should try to establish
a [ __ ] technology transfer
with this [ __ ] hive of [ __ ]
hornets
you know what i mean this beehive yeah
maybe i should
trade maybe i should give them fire
let's see what happens you wouldn't do
it
that's that's well that's why i kind of
feel like a lot of
you know early sci-fi like 50 sci-fi and
stuff like that
they were coming at it from a very a
really arrogant
or a very human-centric standpoint it's
like
you're assuming that these aliens that
are like millions of years ahead of us
would actually even [ __ ] care like
what we were
doing and like would usually try to come
here and communicate and like make all
this effort and stuff i just don't think
they would and i'm not saying that i
don't think that aliens exist i'm sure
they i'm sure they do someplace
have they been here that's a whole other
question i just
in a lot of ways i don't think they
would bother you know what i'm saying
there's been some sightings of some
weird [ __ ] over the years yeah but it's
like
it's hard to just brush off and so i'm
not saying that they don't like cruise
by sometimes but all the people that
said oh
yeah i don't really think they care i
think they just kind of are are going
around like checking
like hey how they doing all right
whatever we're gonna go check the next
one
some of this stuff like the tehran ufo
um some of the stuff kind of like the
the tic tac ufo pilot stuff that pilots
had seen
the the real um uh uh
what what's the arizona what's that
lights the the phoenix the phoenix slice
yeah yeah
some of the phoenix lights were flares
but not all of them um
but we'll do a show on that one of these
show on that one one of these days i put
in the poll but it lost
five signs the governor saw it and he
said it was an extraterrestrial craft
said it had to have been um
but he didn't say so at the time it was
afterwards he's like yeah well wasn't he
like making fun of it at the time like
did you have somebody come out like
dressed like an alien
or something is that what i'm thinking
yeah people thought he was mocking it
but he said he wasn't he was just trying
to take the
the um the edge off of it because
everybody was really
starting to freak out and he saw it too
evidently and he was trying to
calm everybody down because what are you
going to do there was nothing to do
about it
well yeah and he tried to call it up to
washington washington you want to talk
about it it was like we don't know
i don't care what what about what we're
just humans like you [ __ ] we
don't know what's happening
[Laughter]
there's one video that survived and you
will see it on some programs
but it's very grainy and fuzzy because
it was taken with a real
[ __ ] quality vhs camera at night and
you can
see him trying to focus in on it talking
about it it's
far but you can see the five lights in
the v-shape
at an angle off towards the horizon
and um the whole state saw the the
[ __ ] thing
and they're you know they got back up
you know you know the the the people
that
ran 9-1-1 said thousands of people were
[ __ ] calling and it was coming across
the state
you know i mean as it flew across the
state and as it passed cities
the 911 operators started getting hit
there was something they saw something
um and it was odd some people say that
they saw it real clearly and there's a
lot of witnesses and the governor saw it
and he just
he said it was amazing but there was
nothing he could do about it
um yeah
so i think they do come by but i don't
think they're aliens as what you would
as you would think you know i mean
they're probably just like it's
it's a [ __ ] ai probe not even ai
above ai well yeah somebody earlier in
the comments said that it would be like
the borg
be like yeah i think it'd be i don't
think it'd be like the board think it'd
be more like a monolith out of 2001
be like that yeah it'd be the ultimate
expression of [ __ ]
technology and life it is alive it's
intelligent it's
far more intelligent than a human being
we're just bugs compared to it
it's a god-like intellect and it's not
biological
and it's probably not even electrical
it's probably something happening in a
damn quantum realm
it's slightly in another dimension uh
it's just
way way ahead compared to us it would
just be a god
but it's just a
things that float around they're
probably all interconnected like in
their own internet
and who knows
in 2001 they just monitored and seeded
planets
you know to try to maybe uh
making making life happen and improving
on things that are alive
so one day they that that can evolve to
the point where it can make another
artificially intelligent species in
other words it's kind of like
taking care of a nursery you know that
that's that's like what it would be
although i feel like they were kind of
going that direction when they
you know in the movie prometheus but
then they were kind of like seed and
planted
like well we [ __ ] that [ __ ] up so
let's just like [ __ ] wipe them out
let's start over well it took me a long
time to
figure that movie out you know when we
got it on blu-ray i looked at all the
deleted scenes i was trying to piece it
together
over the years the scripts the drafts of
the scripts
uh had leaked and it made a lot more
money
made a lot more sense when you read the
the
the the leaked scripts you're basically
talking about
chariots of the gods and the anunnaki
all right well yeah that's what he got a
lot of the ideas from right
and what had happened was is that they
had evolved to the point
through genetic engineering and stuff
where they had lost
the ability to reproduce they had kind
of like immortality but they couldn't
reproduce
which they didn't think that over time
that would have a lot of profit that
would have uh
uh a bad impact on their species
because they you you could be immortal
but you could still be killed
so they're getting lost by attrition
and evidently they stumbled across the
an alien
that got one of them pregnant and what
hatched out of it
was a hybrid between them and this alien
they called it the deacon and it could
speak it was real intelligent
and they were trying to reproduce
themselves
using this biotechnology thank you
victor
yeah i just got here but have some money
they were trying to use the blood of
this [ __ ]
engineer alien hybrid
deacon hybrid they were trying to use
that blood to reproduce themselves
in into a new form but they ran out of
it it didn't quite work
so then they kind of made a substitute
that was like this black goo they showed
in the movie but that didn't work either
so they were just kind of like a dying
species there was a lot of lore going on
in that
yeah well it was all hooked up with
religion and everything it's just like
what's in eric von danigan's [ __ ] um
chariots of the gods yeah a little bit
because we did a show about the annunaki
didn't we
like all that kind of stuff like ancient
aliens kind of [ __ ]
so what eventually was going to happen
is
that you were going to find out to your
horror that gods were all
true and that jesus was one of them
and and the leaders of all these
religions going back to the greek
religions you know with the [ __ ]
titans and humans worshiping titans and
mount olympus and everything that it was
all about
our gods who had created us created us
in their image
to but they were going to wipe us out
that's what it was
we had we had they were able to give us
gender
again so we could reproduce ourselves
but we were of a tainted strain
so they were going to wipe us out that
was the problem yeah
and wiping us out and all this stuff
kind of lines up with um is that tila
thanks thank you tila thanks babe
what'd you say victor dammit you beat me
too and i just got here have some help
thank you very much
so they were going to take uh it was
going to be a good it was going to be a
good series
there was going to be three of the damn
movies but the aliens fans [ __ ] that
prometheus i kind of wish they'd gone
more in the prometheus direction
rather than back in the alien it's like
they already made a bunch of alien-y
kind of movies yeah those are good
alien stuff you know with the [ __ ]
xenomorphs and everything and that
really is not
that wasn't the important part of the
story the important part of the story
was these engineers
you know and ridley and
ridley kind of [ __ ] bowed to the
alien fanboys and was all right we're
going to make it about
aliens and it it it didn't it didn't
come out as well see now
that's what happens when you try to
please
everybody yeah you can't please anybody
it's a you know what i mean it's just
like i feel like if you're somebody of
the caliber of ridley scott yeah
go with your instincts man it's like
yeah people are gonna some people are
gonna [ __ ] but it's like no matt
you could make the [ __ ] masterpiece
of the world and somebody will still
[ __ ] about it and hate it
so don't worry about it it's gonna be a
badass
series it was going to be about god's
making man and man trying to become gods
all right yeah which is a great theme i
mean it was great
and it was going to combine alien and
blade runner
which were taking place in the same
ridley scott universe
and it was the engineers made us
because they were trying to recreate
themselves
in their image so they and but we were
[ __ ] up so we wanted to become gods
and we were making we were becoming gods
by making creatures in our image
which were robots like androids
and replicants yeah and you were going
to be dealing with
a property that had a bunch of conflict
between
dudes making robots and replicants
and aliens making humans and aliens
making things
xenomorphs and all that was going to be
happening at once
and see that have been [ __ ] bad ass
yeah i kind of would have done the whole
time and if you had the money
you could even throw the predators in
that
because they're in the evidently now let
you know let's not do that but you could
do that later
that'd be a little overstuffed yeah
because i mean you're talking about a
lot of
you know big themes big concepts yeah i
feel like you would just muck it up if
you threw the predators
not that the predators aren't cool but
i'm just saying let them
let them stay in their own movie i don't
like that alien versus predator like
mash up the theatrical release of
prometheus was [ __ ] up because they
edited some [ __ ] out that really should
have been left in the theatrical release
what the what the engineer said to
[ __ ] peter whalen
should have been left in there well that
of course that was a huge
[ __ ] they took us so much
so much it's in the deleted scenes in
the blu-ray
you should have had the [ __ ] you
should have had the engineer talking to
talking to wayland through the robot
and it should have been subtitled at
least so you understood what the hell
was going on
and you know if you haven't seen the
movie or if you haven't seen that
deleted scene
basically the [ __ ] robot
the the engineer comes out of hypersleep
he's like what the hell are you doing
here and
the robot says uh this man has come from
earth
thinking that you created him you know
and then he's like what does he want you
know and he goes he
he thinks that you can give him eternal
life
and the engineer says you know what has
he
done to make him think that he should
deserve eternal life
right yeah and then waylon says
through the interpreter you know he says
see this man right here
my company built him i made him all
right
and he goes i'm a creator like you
and and which was the wrong thing to say
creators
and he goes because i built this man but
he's better than i am because he can
never die he's immortal
and me being a god like you we should
never die and that [ __ ] engineer if i
could rip that robot's head and beat him
to death with it
[ __ ] and and wait a minute hold on
and you're not you're supposed to go he
said the wrong thing
evidently but what was what was it you
know that was wrong about that
and you were going to find out later in
the second movie about how
the aliens that made us hated us
because we made technology and we were
trying to become like gods
well yeah it's like you're kind of a
god-like being and then you have these
little upstarts that you kind of see
like you know like little ants or bugs
or something and they suddenly get like
delusions of grandeur and they're coming
up you're going i'm
just as good as you wonderful yeah
they're like yep right and we were
actually
failures because we were little and weak
and evil
all right with all this corruption and
[ __ ] and sin
so it said you know sin is what they're
taught we were supposed to be a lot
bigger
and a lot better yeah yeah these are not
disappointment
be biologically perfect and and and and
be
immortal and uh and still be able to
reproduce so we were actually the
opposite
and the reason why the engineers all
kill each other is because a war broke
out in heaven or whether or not
they should wipe us out or not yeah all
right well they all wiped each other out
he was the last one because he had faith
that maybe the humans would eventually
evolve into something like them
but he woke up 2 000 years later and
found out no they were
these so he killed all his buddies for
nothing
yeah so that's why he was going to go
deliver the black good wipe the [ __ ]
planet out
yep so in case you didn't see all the
deleted scenes
right yeah yeah and then it's the whole
world it was it was a very biblical
theme it was a war in heaven type
you know warren heaven [ __ ] it it was
actually
written so the bible and greek religions
and and mesoamerica mesopotamian and
mesoamerican religions all
made sense because they all have the
same themes anyway so yeah
so the it was supposed to be a sci-fi
horror movie
that the gods really did exist and they
really did hate us
because we really were a failed
experiment yeah that's that was
which that's a badass concept that's
what i mean that's like a great [ __ ]
theme
right and then you got evil humans
making [ __ ] that's even more
evil replicants and robots you see how
[ __ ] evil those were
wait a minute the [ __ ] what was his
name
uh david he was like a [ __ ] perfect
man but he was total sociopath
yeah total stuff do you have any empathy
but he was the perfect man
yeah the perfect man is a [ __ ]
sociopath that is [ __ ] that kills its
god and kills its creator
so it's exactly along that [ __ ]
i'm telling you man the [ __ ]
drinks too much but really scott's a
[ __ ]
can come up we can't really that's the
pot calling to get back
comes up with some really cool ideas
that's what i mean that's a great
[ __ ] idea
and it's like i you know i like
prometheus a lot of people didn't
but i do think that the concepts of it
could have been
more clear you know what i'm saying it
was a little metal but like i said i
think the
main problem was they took a lot of
stuff out that probably shouldn't have
been
taken out yeah dj maniac said it'd be
like walking up to gordon ramsay and
saying i'm a cook too and then throwing
some hot dogs in boiling water yeah
exactly
exactly well yeah it's funny because
we for some reason like last night
because i was like really really tired
and i was like um i was like i just want
to watch something kind of fun that's
like not that i don't have to
concentrate too hard on
so i noticed that hulu has like all 10
seasons of masterchef
and i haven't really kept up i think i
saw the first five or six seasons and
then i kind of like
forgot about it so i started watching
season 10
last night and um man i l
i love [ __ ] gordon ramsay shows i
like masterchef because i mean i like
kitchen nightmares too
but i kind of enjoy shows more
where people are good at [ __ ] you know
what i mean because i know there's a
whole sub
genre of these kind of like reality or
competition type shows
it's like look at these losers that
can't cook and we're gonna make them
cook things and look how they [ __ ]
everything up because i think there's
one called nailed it
uh you know where they hey make a cake
that looks like this and it just looks
like [ __ ] sad
um that's not really that fun for me
like just watching people fail
over and over um so i actually like
stuff like masterchef where those people
actually do most of the time know what
they're doing
i'm not saying i don't enjoy every now
and then when somebody gets [ __ ] on
because
like the one i was watching i think i
watched like the first two or three
shows on masterchef this was season 10.
and the one guy that was there
i can't remember what his name was but
he was like that dude from he was from
boston
and he was like real like super boston
and like super
italian and he made this dish
i can't even what it was but like the
way he plated it
they said it tasted okay but they said
the way he plated it like joe said that
looks like a fungal infection and i was
like
oh man it really did i mean it looked
like some kind of diseased
i don't know what he was thinking they
said it tasted all right though it
wasn't great but it was like okay
they're like well it tastes a little bit
better than it looks but it looks like
[ __ ] horrendous
but most of the people on there are like
actually pretty good and actually do
know what they're doing
but like i said i'm only on the third or
fourth one and the first two were
you know winnowing out because however
many [ __ ]
100 people they get in there to like be
in the finals and then they like winnow
it down to 20.
so the first two episodes were that like
winnowing down the people to 20.
so that was the ones i watched and then
i watched like one or two more they're
in there talking about um
gods of egypt and exodus and stuff like
that which
i guess those are um other uh
what's his name movies you know i'm
getting drunk
yeah that's that dude's name scott we're
gonna be incoherent by that really scott
i can remember the one that remember
that one that he did about the the ship
trapped up in the ice i really thought
that was gonna be good
it was good but it was just very
underwhelming wait the ship dropped in
the ice
yeah the ship got the ship that got
trapped up in the ice and there were
some inuits up there and they kept
getting attacked by gigantic polar bear
that was a really scott series members
of series what the terror
i think it was called the terror wasn't
it maybe maybe yeah wait did ridley
scott direct that i think that was
ridley scott
i just remember it was based on a dan
simmons book i thought that was really
scott
i liked it though yeah yeah and it was
based on a real thing
that happened also yeah but i don't
think the uh
i don't remember it i don't think there
was a polar bear eating people was there
or a massive magical mystical polar bear
maybe we're talking about different
things
[Laughter]
i watched it with you they were trapped
up in the ice yeah yeah and towards the
end
they were getting picked off by i guess
it was a polar bear
and it was summoned by that inuit woman
yeah
that was trying to get revenge for
because they killed her dad yeah
never yeah i'm pretty sure i don't think
that actually happened in real life but
that [ __ ] well no but
that ship did get trapped it's based on
a book though right like i read the book
a long time ago
yeah good acting you know just it was
just kind of underwhelming by today's
standards hard to compete with a modern
story
um i didn't see i didn't see gods of
egypt though
[ __ ] ridley scott is hit and miss
about certain things he's good with
blade runner type stuff and aliens he's
best with science fiction i think
just well he's like a big ideas guy yeah
you know what i mean he's like one of
those dudes that like he has to come up
with some ideas yeah like go way out
there
yeah that was just good visual stylist
too i think there was so much
meddling in the prometheus thing they
[ __ ] up a good thing that was going to
be a really good series but
like they mentioned it had christian
overtones and the
the the studios didn't want that and
they wanted more of it
they wanted alien too you know what i
mean
again and that's gonna happen i mean
well the thing about it
is that the thing that you have with a
lot of the studios i don't even know if
they care
like what the overtones are they're just
like well we want something that's
familiar to people
because that is what we'll bring money
in if you try to do something new and
different
then it's a risk for them you know what
it means they're putting like millions
sometimes billions of dollars on the
line so like we don't want
you know anything that's kind of risky
or anything that's going to piss people
off or anything's going to do like that
so they try to like
you know stay as safe and neutral as
possible yeah
which you know like i said obviously
doesn't always work out it doesn't work
it's
big budget movies aren't going to work
out anymore like i said you try to
please everybody and you end up pleasing
nobody because it ends up just being
kind of bland
yep those big tent poll that's why emc
is gone
they went ahead and said that they don't
now
they didn't want to admit it at the time
but the studios and amc
that [ __ ] business model is never to
return ever
you're just not going to get that much
excitement about movies anymore not with
the young
younger people they don't care it's not
it's not in their culture
well culture's going away and the thing
about it too is that
i mean you have to think that people
that are young right now
they gave up all this imagery well and
they've grown up too with just being
able to see pretty much any movie you
want like on your [ __ ] laptop like
whenever you want to watch it you don't
have to go to the theater and see it
when you think about it the only
big events that we actually
in that year and a half that we had that
[ __ ] amc
pass which i liked that actually yeah i
did too
but that's gone now the only real big
events where you go
and you're like oh this is gonna be some
[ __ ] today this is gonna be fantastic
it was john wick every time we went to
go see those john wick's movies it was a
[ __ ] blowout
yeah that was always fun yeah and uh
avengers and games the avengers end game
yeah and
the rest of that [ __ ] was just kind of
like the crowds were mediocre and you
could tell that it wasn't really that
big of a deal
um just that era
that era i think is kind of gone um
i think there'll be theaters there's
just there's not gonna be as many of
them it's not it's not really a thing
well like i said it's probably gonna go
the route of smaller theaters
more indie fair more kind of themed
nights where they show like older stuff
like retrospectives and stuff
which i think is a cool idea because
like i said there's a lot of movies that
came out before my time
that i would like to see on the big
screen because i never got to
i mean i was really excited when they
started doing those old like when amc
started doing like they did the shining
and alien and stuff because i never got
to see those on the big screen
so i thought that was like really cool
that they were doing that things that
are brick and mortar i don't think are
gonna make it
the future of a movie is gonna be a
streaming services like we have now
and a certain day it releases you pay
extra money and you're gonna put vr
goggles on
that's what adventures in the movie and
it's gonna be
like a a 360 degree
experience you know what i mean with
headphones
and you're in your own home probably you
know and it just
goes into your xbox controller port or
whatever i don't know
it's wireless they don't have controller
ports anymore and
uh you're gonna have kind of like a
something even better than a theater
experience
and you'll pay 15 bucks for that
something like that
that's probably what it's going to be
maybe smell-o-vision
yeah i kind of feel like john waters
wanted that because wasn't it when
[ __ ] man was it was the john waters
movie that came out
um and they distributed when you went to
see it in the theater
they distributed scratch and sniff cards
with like [ __ ] there was like
you said there was like poop smell that
was like all this kind of tastes like
i love john somebody said
okay did ridley scott direct thelma
louise
i didn't know that hold up i don't know
holy crap
somebody to wikipedia i can't go to
wikipedia on here yeah
i didn't know that i mean that doesn't
sound right but
i'm not gonna like dispute because i
don't know i can't check
i don't think i love selma louise i
don't think screens are the future
i think the future goggles that's that's
what i think of the future's gonna be
they're gonna get that right eventually
or it will be something where
it's a headband you put on and somehow
it uses some kind of radiation or some
kind of
some kind of electromagnetism to
stimulate your [ __ ] brain
directly and you start seeing things or
you experience things as if you're there
might be something like that google says
yes what
i'll be damned okay i didn't know ridley
scott directed them louise
that's a great [ __ ] movie i haven't
seen it so long i can't give an opinion
on it anymore oh it's so good
yeah do you want a drink yeah why not
where's pookie is she still inside we
had
one of her one of the floppy fish i mean
the floppy fish they belong to both the
kitties because i got two of them one
for each of them
even though pookie seems to be the only
one that plays with them
one of the fish is like it still
uh makes the noise like it still goes
whack a mark mark
whatever but you know the little
mechanism in it that makes the tail flop
for some reason
i think pookie like either sat on it or
she like [ __ ] it up or something
and it like bent so it was like
making the noise but the tail wasn't
flopping because the little
armature wasn't going up and down so tom
had to go in there
and like pull the whole thing out like
pull the whole little armature inside
out
and he had to like reshape like the
little pegs because it's like a
it's like a battery pack thing and then
there's like a little
arm that comes out with like a little
like little pegs that fit in there
and i guess she she made them like
misshapen
from [ __ ] with the fish
so it's like [ __ ] how long did that last
not even a month
because i gave her those for christmas
so it was like now she then she was like
looking at it like well it's just it's
making the noise but it's not moving i
don't understand what the [ __ ] is
happening
but he fixed it so i guess they're
they're both flopping now
i just feel like if she if she sits on
it and like
you know [ __ ] up the [ __ ] again we're
gonna have to like [ __ ]
he had to like heat up the plastic and
like melt the plastic like back into
shape so it would fit back into the [ __ ]
so that's what i mean there's [ __ ]
these [ __ ] cats
um let's see uh where was i
yeah tila says i think movie theaters
are coming back just a matter of time
i think probably they are too um but
like i said i think it's going to be
like a much smaller enterprise because i
still i like going to the theater [ __ ]
when i used to live in
um on something
when i used to um live in daytona
they had this really small it wasn't
even like a movie theater movie theater
it was just kind of like
a couple of rooms and they just had like
a big screen and a projection
and every tuesday they had like um
there was like an indie movie club or
something in daytona and they would
show like an indie movie like tuesday
afternoons and tuesday evenings or
whatever
and so i would just because it was only
like a mile or two for my house so
tuesdays because i used to work nights
so i was off during the day
so i would ride my bicycle down there
every tuesday and see whatever they had
it was just one movie
you know what i mean it wasn't like you
had a bunch you could pick from but they
even had like a little thing in the
front where they'd make like coffee and
hot chocolate they had like popcorn and
cookies and [ __ ] like that
you just go back there and like [ __ ]
watch whatever the
whatever the latest indie movie was they
showed like documentaries foreign it was
like it was really fun
so i think that a lot of um movie
theaters might be going like that
and you might see stuff like like in
orlando we have enzian
the enzian theater which is essentially
the same kind of thing they usually show
like indie movies and
they also have like a cafe you know what
i mean so you just sit in there and
there's tables and you can get wine and
beer and you can
have a little you know you can have
little meals and [ __ ] like that tila
says she thinks uh movie theaters are
coming back
yeah that's not sure i don't know about
big like multiplexes
but i think smaller ones might i think
that era might be gone
um we just have to wait to see what
happens i mean you have to look
at the history of movie making
they made a lot of [ __ ] movies you go
back to the [ __ ] early 1900s and
1920s they were making junk back then
they were making many movies a month
yeah and uh it
they're all forgotten and
a lot it was just it was junk that they
[ __ ] because they were on silver
nitrate stock yeah they just
mostly junk [ __ ] very few of them were
classics
um well they kind of continued doing
that
up until the present day most of the
movies that we
saw over that on that program
most of them were forgettable yeah most
of them weren't bad they were just kind
of like
you know you and you kind of enjoyed
them when you watched them but then like
you didn't even remember because
like a year later and be like wait did i
see that yeah
and it's because they make too many
goddamn movies uh
what they should do is come on in pope
well hey oh you closed the door too much
she's like i can't
get it open i can't get it come on come
on come here
she's just like sitting there going is
it okay can i come in you're coming
you can come in you want to be on the
show come up here a second
yeah come up here she's down there what
are you doing
it's the pookie countdown
[Music]
the pokey countdown i'm sure we probably
mentioned this on the show before
but i've gotten into the habit of
singing uh pookie various like cheesy
songs like from the 70s and 80s except
replacing some of the words with
pookie's name
and um so yesterday i kind of for
whatever reason
you i don't know if you guys remember
that song by the tubes she's a beauty
yeah i don't know why i just randomly
thought of it when i was like in the
shower or something
and then i started so i started singing
it to her except it was
she's a pookie obviously and um and then
so before we went on the stream
like we were coming up with all these i
was we were kind of like all these
[ __ ] 70s and 80 songs that we could
put poke in there i was like hey pookie
two shoes
it was like that [ __ ] adam ant song
and it's like
i don't know she probably thinks i'm a
crazy person because she knows what her
name is
so when i sing to her she's probably
just like she usually puts up with it
except one time when i was singing
dancing queen
except it was pookie queen and then i
was making everything like cat
oriented like all the lyrics she's
looking at you like what and then she
i was like she was laying down with me
in the closet and then like she just
very deliberately got up and walked out
she's like yeah [ __ ] that [ __ ] i was
like sorry
she put she'll put up with neil diamond
she'll put up with the oscar meyer theme
song i did that for a little while
she's a poop girl and she's going too
far but she doesn't really
matter anyway you can rely on the old
books money
you can rely on the old poke's
why don't you come up here come up here
it's like anybody wants to see your
little booty
all right somebody's asked me what the
rule of steel is i gotta go
you gotta go through this [ __ ] again
riddle of steel
okay in the beginning of the movie
conan's dad tells him that the riddle of
steel
it was known by the gods but the secret
of steel was lost on the battlefield
and so this is a post-apocalyptic
apocalyptic thing
and he says steel is [ __ ] strong in
this
you can trust you can't trust animals
you can't trust
men you can't trust women but this sword
you can trust and then the next scene
his dad's
in the middle of the damn village and a
[ __ ] invading army comes and he's out
there with that sword and a [ __ ]
pack of wild dogs [ __ ] eats him alive
and then that sword ends up in the hands
of thulson doom
all right so it's not true you can't
rely on [ __ ] steel
sorry i just left because scott was like
she's one in a million cats yeah that's
what we were singing that's what we were
doing
yeah she's the pool gate yeah then later
on you got dulce doom
and if you understand who thousand doom
is
and his technique he he's a wizard
wizards are about [ __ ] subversion
they subvert you they're trying to get
a scientologist yeah yeah they try to
get you to look inward and try to
[ __ ] think and looking for infinity
and
[ __ ] like that and what do you do you
sell your soul to it and then they
[ __ ] eat you
all right because you notice at the
temple of dulce doom there wasn't any
crops or anything they just had an orgy
[ __ ] orgy and sex and then they just
ate each other
it's a [ __ ] circular firing squad
it's exactly what he's talking about
all right so all right
this is john millius writing this man
he's a [ __ ] anti-communist right
that's exactly what he's talking about
dr dim comes down and says the riddle is
still
you know you killed my father you killed
my whole family
[Laughter]
of course like and of course
also do because oh the riddle of steel
you know
you don't you know it don't you boy you
know
[ __ ] he's the [ __ ] first of all you
have to understand
you have to understand
[ __ ] i get to admit
[Laughter]
you're dealing with the prehistoric
darth vader
okay and [ __ ]
is this what the hell was that i heard
something laughing
it's the it's the floppy fish oh it's
the floppy fish dude yeah it goes
okay all right yeah yeah that's its
little tail going like so um
oh [ __ ] what's the name of the actor
that uh [ __ ] um clayton also doom
[ __ ] what's his name um
[ __ ] guy's name
well i'm not gonna tell you just because
it's funny to like watch you [ __ ] all
right dan [ __ ] it [ __ ] that
come on i can't remember either
i mean i can but like come on i couldn't
[ __ ] better i took my time
all right in the comments section go
ahead and tell me who that was
he's the voice of darth vader he was
saying he was in [ __ ] um
dr strangelove
james jones you guys
[Laughter]
he's he's uh he's from mississippi you
know [ __ ] darth vader from
mississippi he's an army ex-army ranger
you know
james james earl jones was a [ __ ]
afro-irish ranger from mississippi
okay that's exactly what you're dealing
with all right jones
so dawson doom says uh oh you know the
riddle of steel don't you boy
let me go ahead and tell you the riddle
of steel that's the least i could do
before i [ __ ] kill your ass on the
[ __ ] tree of whoa
all right you look at that tree you go
whoa whoa
but anyway he goes steel isn't strong
because flesh is stronger and then he
gets the girl to jump and then he goes
he goes
what is steel compared to your hand what
is still compared you know
see saying that what you can rely on
is you it is is
your body and other people you know what
i mean and your ability to influence
other people that you can rely on that
okay since that's what the secret to the
riddle of steel is
well turns out that was [ __ ] too
because later on [ __ ] conan with a
broken sword
cuts [ __ ] thulsa doom's head off with
it just
hacks it off so now flash isn't strong
either
okay and um conan sits at the base of
the [ __ ] temple of doom or the
[ __ ]
mount what is it called the mountain of
power that's like temple
so he's sitting there thinking about it
and he realizes in his mind what the
[ __ ] answer the riddle of steel is
weapons are strong because weapons can
fail you
flesh isn't strong because your flesh
can fail you because
you you can just get tired you can get
old and sick and die
you can lose your someone could cut your
head off you never know
even a broken sword can cut a head off
so
nah flesh isn't strong either what's
strong
is will the will to act have
conan not done any of this [ __ ] he
wouldn't have [ __ ] all that [ __ ] up
and won
at the very end he's seeing the [ __ ]
mountain of power saying
i could take over i could become the
next cult leader the next sorcerer
but that's not the kind of power i want
he burned it down
so that's that's that's the secret of it
is that
and and it it goes ahead and tells you
right at the beginning of the [ __ ]
movie
it says that which does not kill you
makes you stronger there's a quote by
nietzsche friedrich nietzsche and
true steel the true
power comes from the will to act it
without action
there's no there's nothing and um
in the very beginning when conan's in
the pit
and [ __ ] his chroniclers telling he
goes conan
in front of that all of them he mattered
because he he was fighting in the pit
struggling for survival
in front of the [ __ ] roaring crowd
while he was killing people
then they cut some [ __ ] out they were
there was a scene where conan kills two
women down in there that he was fighting
they would say the conan had no
boundaries and the crowd was [ __ ]
worshiping worshipping and giving giving
him all his [ __ ] praise
and that's where he got his sense of
self-worth and
and and down in the pit he realized that
he mattered that what he did matter
that's the first lesson in the movie
what you do matters if you don't do
anything then you don't [ __ ] matter
that's what it means i thought you were
going to say that
i don't know i don't know i want to make
a joke
it's like mind over matter if you don't
mind it don't matter either
[Laughter]
if you don't do anything no matter i
thought you were going to say the only
thing that
the only thing that is that matters is
the power of love
that's the only power no [ __ ] conan
just like huey lewis said
it's the pool yeah no there was a scene
kind of like that where that tibetan
warlord
asked says right here says conan what's
best in life
you know yes his son what's best in life
he goes oh man freedom and having an
eagle on your side your horse good horse
and
the wind and all this [ __ ]
high-minded [ __ ] look at his dead went
ah [ __ ] what do you what what's the
best one conan he goes
[ __ ] winning basically he says
crushing your enemies seeing them run in
front of you and hearing
their women crying over it so conan was
more right well what really matters in
life is winning
winning you don't want to be a loser
that's that's the that's the
what is best in life winning
zack says do you guys like turkey
manhattan's i don't even know what the
hell those are
that sounds like a really weird cocktail
but yet intriguing
[Laughter]
i would eat a turkey martini or drink it
i guess i don't know it's hip to be poop
[Laughter]
that's a good one too oh my god it's
like [ __ ] endless
she probably gets sick of us singing to
her all the time she's like you guys are
insane
i can't believe you're my parents you
know dj manic says he loves hearing me
talk about movies like a maniac
five-year-old tell the story a manic
five-year-old daddy
yeah you do kind of sound like that yeah
it's just kind of like i remember
because i have um you know you have the
people that have watched shows this is
about mythology mythology is always
simple
i have a lot of primal i have a lot of
uh i have two
younger brothers and a younger sister so
when i was growing up
my little brothers were really into like
video games and stuff so it's like
they'd always try to tell you know how
like when you're a little boy
and you're like trying to tell your mom
about all the [ __ ] that you did in the
video game and it's like
i've been playing zelda and then like i
had to kill this [ __ ] thing and like
did it
and all this other kind of stuff and the
mom's like that's nice honey and all
that
it's always kind of like that
you do kind of
see i see i always like ideally i feel
like it has to be something it doesn't
necessarily have to rhyme with pookie
but it has to have that same i mean it
has to be two syllables and it has to
have that same kind of like
you know what i mean it has to have that
same kind of assonance to it or that
same kind of
you know what i mean because that i
guess that's why i thought she's a
beauty would be good because i was like
beauty pookie that kind of sounds the
same
and it you know it occupies the same
like linguistic space i suppose
it's hard to think of something i for a
long time i was getting into
this is how much i think about this
because like apparently i don't have
anything better to do
but um i started singing for some reason
i started singing her the oscar
theme song one day like you know my
pookie has a first name p-o-o-k-y
but then like when i got to the end i
couldn't really think of anything that
would
that i could spell out like for the
final [ __ ] that would like rhyme
with the rest of the song so i kind of
abandoned it i am this this is the same
person i'll have to find it
but i wrote on facebook and this is
probably like two or three years ago
for some reason i was standing in the
shower and i
came up with an entire alternate set of
lyrics
to old-time rock and roll that terrible
bob sager song
that had to do with pookie
throwing dvds off of the shelf because
she wanted treats
yeah it's a i wrote a whole song about
it
and it totally works if you sing it in
that register
and it just came to me in one flashlight
kind of run right up to a damn shelf and
start throwing things off the [ __ ]
shelf
and then look at you
it's ridiculous well she knows she knows
that if you make a lot of noise or if
you throw things off the thing then
she gets your attention so it's like
what she'll do if she wants more treats
or she wants to go outside or she wants
now we have like these meat sticks that
we get from chewy
and they're in like tom's nightstand
like the with the
with the drawer so she knows that
they're in there because she's seen us
take them out she tries
so she tries to open the drawer and she
can't get in there and it's like really
frustrating
so then she'll come around to the side
of his nightstand and she
her little head will pop up and then she
puts her paw up like that and then she's
like takes whatever is and she's like
knocks it off so it makes a lot of noise
either that or she like bangs on the um
the blinds for the window right there
she's like and then she goes to the
drawer
do you know what i was doing while
you're in here working what went ahead
and got down that old haunting
this little haunting series oh yeah you
said you were gonna do that
it was watching the beginning of season
one i saw summer wind in there
about where's the raccoon and everything
and it was kind of it was kind of nice
to go back
to uh early 2000's television
there's something about that format
we're relaxing
well the show haunting is is something
very soon because we used to sometimes
like put that
on like the dvd just play all episodes
and then like you just like
lay down and kind of take a nap yeah
it's just like something about the music
is like i don't know it's just really
relaxing something about old television
it was designed to be very soothing and
to keep you calm i think
it's nothing like [ __ ] youtube
youtube is [ __ ] always like agitating
you
well it's like [ __ ] clickbait yeah
and like i said it's kind of like
page bait well and remember too like i
was talking about that movie yesterday
that movie spree which i actually liked
but
it was kind of and i mean i get that it
was parodying that
like that kind of hyper yeah um you know
social media thing where it's like you
know everybody like you have to be
watching me like at all times so it's
like you know
click click like all this kind of stuff
so it's like it was kind of like that
but
there is a lot of that kind of [ __ ]
going on but you you know it's i don't
really have that hard of a time
unplugging from that i don't you know i
don't know
i don't know i don't really have that
hard at the time unplugging from that i
really don't
yeah you don't know a thing but um what
was i oh i was gonna say something
you're indifferent to everything
no it's not it's not that i'm
indifferent it's just
i've gotten to a point in my life where
because i feel like a lot of my youth i
was kind of
just worried about everything and i was
like over anxious and i was like i kind
of
thought that i could control
more things that i could control you got
a lot he got old once i got
old and i was kind of like you know what
it's like really i
there's a lot of [ __ ] that i can't
control and that's okay
like and me stressing out about it is
not helping anything it's just making me
feel bad and it
wouldn't change anything one way or the
other so
i just kind of got this weird zen
it's not that i don't care i do but
there comes a point where i don't know
it's not apathy exactly
i don't know if you guys know what i'm
talking about it's not i'm not apathetic
i do care about [ __ ]
it's just that i think i have a
realistic
sense of things i can control and things
that i can't control
you know what i'm saying yeah she was
saying the same thing you're right back
when the history channel was all like
that
you could sit back there and just watch
the history channel and the history
channel would just
chill you the [ __ ] out i used to love
the history channel is the history
channel all
ancient aliens now i don't know because
i feel like the travel channel is all
paranormal normal now it seems like i
don't maybe not but it really does seem
like it's all that now
they were showing like ancient
technologies and things that you know
just going back well the history channel
used to actually have like cool
documentaries about history on it i
think it does
i mean does it still i don't know i
don't watch it yeah i think it does but
i think it split into a couple different
channels
well like one of them is nothing but
just like iceberg truckers or some [ __ ]
like ice road truckers
iceberg i call it iceberg trucker well
the thing about it is that i can see why
a lot of
okay so a lot of these channels like
discovery history did this like a travel
channel everything
they went in a more reality show
direction because
one reality shows you know get a lot of
people watching them
and two because they're super cheap to
produce they're like way cheaper to
produce than like a regular actual
informative deck i don't think
television is functional
anymore well no i'm just saying that
that's why they went a lot in that
direction because
you know that's really cheap to produce
and that does get the most eyeballs for
your investment
that was like 2010s and i think it
started to peter out
i had to look at it now but last i heard
most of those channels um don't get any
views
like and it's like a pitiful amount of
[ __ ] views
like you might have like
a one of those channels only gets like
[ __ ] 10 000 views a day
according to the [ __ ] cable people
that's pretty [ __ ] that's piss poor
terrible and it's funny because like
hallmark channel is now like one of the
more popular ones
and but it has to do with the fact that
it's on it's on in all the old people's
homes and all the convalescent homes
it's [ __ ] hallmark channel well yeah
because they look
to be honest though i didn't know this
but like hallmark channel and lifetime
and stuff
it's like every [ __ ] year
they make like 40 bajillion that's an
excellent
vision yeah christmas movies christmas
yeah hallmark channel
makes like a [ __ ] like 20 christmas
movies a year
yeah and like they do a whole somebody
asked did i cut my hair
is it just pull back it's pulled back i
had it down earlier but it was like
pissing me off it was like kind of
hanging in my face so i just pulled it
back you know
but um yeah so i don't know somebody's
watching this [ __ ] i do i do feel like
it's old people probably yeah or people
that
they just have it on like i go to the
gym when i go to the va
every every television has hallmark
channel on it
every one of them can you know in all
the waiting rooms
that's what they play i would imagine
there's probably televisions in
prisons and and uh
dennis offices tennis offices
airports you know what i mean [ __ ] like
that but i don't think
i don't think it's uh well look at this
look at how ridiculous this is
there's a [ __ ] [ __ ] million
channels i scrolled through it about a
year ago to see all the channels that we
have that we never watch
and some of those channels are nothing
but a single
infomercial yeah just over and over and
over and over and over again because
apparently some people
are still buying something off of
infomercials well somebody's gonna be
doing it or would have like withered up
i feel like there has to be i think it's
people in trailers out in the middle of
nowhere well yeah
um they don't know maybe about
amazon or their old they don't have
internet or they're too old to know how
to use internet
yeah and it's always stuff that it's
always stuff that like an old person
would buy it's [ __ ] collector's
plates
but yeah it's like qvc yeah like tacky
like cheap
jewelry they're telling you how how
[ __ ] rare
and exotic this [ __ ] dollar necklace
is you're looking at that [ __ ] going i'm
gonna [ __ ] that [ __ ]
it's like something you get it like
something you see at cvs man some five
year old at time in thailand probably
made that you guys
but yeah so robot so is that yeah
china makes it yeah zach said um yeah
that's what i said isn't the travel
channel nothing but paranormal shows now
i think it is
it's every time like i don't watch the
traffic animal's channel was that
have we talked about that before yeah no
tell them about that
so anthony that's atlanta that's animal
planet like and like i said i haven't
watched like tv tv for
probably at least five years maybe
longer
but animal planet used to have like some
kind of cool shows about you know hey
here's like a veterinarian and they're
going about you know it was like
informative [ __ ] about animals which is
what you would expect
but then it's like [ __ ] started to seep
in because paranormal shows are super
popular and like i said they're like
really really cheap to produce you just
have to like film some
dumb ass like walking through an
abandoned place with a
camera it costs nothing so and and being
like
did you hear that you know what i mean
it's they're all like that so
animal planet started their own
paranormal show
because that's a thing that you do and
that's the thing that all the kids were
doing those days
so it's like their show what the [ __ ]
was it called i don't even remember what
it was i don't even think it had
anything to do with animals but it was
just some kind of like it was a
paranormal show
and it was basically a straight-up
paranormal show except that they had to
at least take five or ten seconds to
mention that the family had a pet
a cat or dog and the cat or dog was
acting really weird one day
so that so that means paranormal yeah
that was that was it
there was like one i think we watched
like a couple of episodes of that just
which is
obvious that the [ __ ] there's a shoe
horn
get some shots of the cat looking upset
yeah it's basically an episode of the
haunting and then they
shoehorn five seconds of and you know
our cat
have a kitty going the cat was our cat
knew that the ghost was looking at the
corner and
that's the last time you see the gap and
you don't see it and it's
just contrasting it was so [ __ ] fun
actually
some but the pet has to be in the
[ __ ] story somewhere it was so
[ __ ] [ __ ] ridiculous
all that [ __ ] is [ __ ] ridiculous tv
is [ __ ] ridiculous
it is yeah it's [ __ ] ridiculous but
like it was ridiculous back in the day
well they're always trying to like jump
on
the the latest bandwagon and like i said
it's kind of like movies it's like
nobody likes when you're putting
millions of dollars
of investment into something you don't
want to
take a risk with something that you
don't know
is you know that's why they did so many
remakes that's why they do
that's why like reality shows are
popular so it's like hey
let's everybody do those now so i feel
like that's
you know like i said i haven't watched
cable in a really long time but it did
feel like history and discovery and
everything like that um you know all
those kind of channels
which used to have really cool [ __ ] on
it like you know really interesting like
documentaries about actual history and
actual science and stuff
tv says possessed pets in one of them oh
i haven't seen that one victor garcia
says ouija cat on animal planet
[Laughter]
i i might watch that i'm not gonna lie
they had a pet psychic i believe it
garcia
are you telling me you watch television
you watch animal planet
no he's making that up okay i don't know
he might be
see that's the thing you don't know i
don't know i mean is that a joke
i have to go back and see i mean we
haven't watched [ __ ] television in a
long long time
it was bad television was always bad but
you didn't really know
it was that bad when you didn't know any
different
well it's not like you had a huge amount
invested in
it's like you just come home from work
you know you'd heat up your tv dinner or
whatever
and then like you well just you know
hypothetically yeah and then you would
just like sit down and like [ __ ]
watch whatever was on you know what i
mean
you'd watch whatever i watched all these
paranormal shows
i thought they were stupid but it's like
every time there was something else on i
remember every time i turned a tv on it
was always like
[ __ ] late and it was like [ __ ] like
sally jesse raphael or [ __ ]
peralta or [ __ ] just
something that remember that [ __ ]
[ __ ] television they used to have
i used to watch that sometimes just
because that's what was always on
because everything else was just [ __ ]
lame as [ __ ] and if
you were home during the day and like i
said a lot of times i was home during
the day because i
worked at night for a long time so
sometimes you know i didn't sit down and
watch it but sometimes i would have it
on in the background
um while i was doing it like cleaning or
doing whatever our internet was jerry
springer
yeah i i never got into i never got into
jerry springer because even that was
i thought it was too it was too early it
was awesome the first couple
seasons but then it became obvious that
it was fake
and that everything was staged well yeah
because they ran out of guess
yeah people didn't want to go on the
show anymore so they
[Laughter]
well that kind of went even like the
kind of the relatively i mean compared
to like
jerry springer and what was the older
one morton downey jr compared to like
those which were kind of like the
the extreme kind of outliers you had
sally jesse
raphael you had ricky lake um geraldo
which was kind of
a gray area but that purported to be
serious
but most of that [ __ ]
i don't like obviously those were real
people but i think a lot of those
were not um who they were purporting to
be
on the show no they were fake because we
know somebody was on one yeah i
i think those were actors generally or
they were people that they just wanted
to [ __ ] show off that wanted to show
off so they like had a good story so
they came to you and said like hey they
made up a story and then victor garcia
[ __ ]
admitted that he made that up that ouija
cat is is
i told you even i'm not that dumb i was
like well i was like i'm not saying
that i'm i'm not saying that that show
couldn't exist
that couldn't exist it wouldn't surprise
me yeah animal
animal planet would do well by putting a
[ __ ] show up there called ouija cat
oh my god i'm going to get pookie a
ouija board yeah and it would be
a kid let's see if she
the cats watching them [ __ ] do the
ouija board and then haunting happens
and no the cat has to do the ouija board
yeah the cat puts it
on there she has to put both her paws on
that cat can't read though other people
have to read
what the cat so you know and
it should be called ouija cat and then
and then and then it's kind of like one
of those ghost hunter programs
yeah you know at the same time the cats
going through this [ __ ] go what the [ __ ]
they got the lights the [ __ ]
microphones like taps you know
oh i couldn't see it ouija cat [ __ ]
right i'll make a million bucks with
that that's actually
not on television there's no money on
television it's actually a pretty good
idea
if somebody could like do a youtube
channel of that see you'd probably get a
zillion views if you did
a little bit tongue-in-cheek yeah but
not so tongue-in-cheek if you like ghost
brothers
all right well it's still funny but
ghost brothers was like one of the best
newer ghost ones that i like well just
because i don't give a [ __ ] about the
ghosts i just thought they were funny
yeah like they had really good chemistry
dudes black dudes in haunted houses
doing fun and i'm sure that's exactly
how they pitched
that's whatever channel that was how
that [ __ ] was pitched
ghost brothers they're like hey you know
how there's that you know terrible
stereotype that like
you know uh black people are like really
are afraid of ghosts or like every time
they go to horror movies they're like
they're like yeah we want to make a
whole show out of that
yeah and it was again delightful
guarantee that [ __ ] those guys were
funny as [ __ ] they were [ __ ] funny
they were funny [ __ ] i loved those guys
is that even still on probably yeah the
only reason i say that because like i
said i don't watch
travel channel anymore but every now and
then like i got a list because i guess
like i entered a contest or some [ __ ]
like that a long time ago
so i still get emails from the travel
channel and it's like on the little side
of the email it always there's
their schedule like what's on right now
and it seems like
what's on like for the next three hours
is always paranormal shows
and it's different ones it's like hey
it's
ghosts of new orleans it's you know
we're going to this place and then maybe
there's there
we're traveling around looking at ghosts
that's pretty much the whole entire
[ __ ] thing of the
just like this i feel like discovery
channel is nothing but ancient aliens
now
there may be history it's not ancient
aliens
it just seems like that's always on
though no it's not what's that one show
that was on
[ __ ] man was it on history or discovery
i don't even think of ancient aliens
it's a thing anymore mysteries at the
museum i like that show
because that show he would just basic
they talked about
all kinds it was kind of like our show
actually they would kind of talk about
all kind of [ __ ]
it was just kind of like about weird
untold miss it was like murders or it
was
like some bank heist that happened back
in the 20s or like some [ __ ] like that
like anything that you could find you
know um
like an artifact of in a museum like
that they could talk about like a whole
story about it
and then they would do like two or three
on every episode that was [ __ ] great
yeah because you could like find out all
kind of [ __ ] and it was just like all
over the place it wasn't just like one
thing
kanavatsalan is in the chat
tila says tina says uh yeah eddie murphy
did a [ __ ] skit remember that's kid
where he was talking about the
black people moved into the house yeah
what's up sorry
[Laughter]
because well if you don't stay you don't
have a movie you have a movie if that
yeah you don't have a movie if they
don't if they don't that's exactly what
that is well i feel like they've
at least nowadays when they make a
horror movie they they at least try to
like pay lip service to that saying well
there's some reason that they can't
leave
yeah well like oh i'm under house arrest
or i can't afford
well just look at what happened look
what happened to me and [ __ ] red and
lois
we couldn't leave the [ __ ] road was
[ __ ] snowed exactly see you always
need a reason we
would have left probably but because in
real life people would be like yeah
look all [ __ ] drunken nonsense
aside all right
you see this [ __ ] it [ __ ] scares the
[ __ ] out of you
all right you want to run you do run
maybe you'll run into another room
but then kind of like curiosity gets the
best of you you're like no that couldn't
have happened
did that really happen see i just did
and then
me and red would be like dude did you
see that what happens if we you know and
then you go back in there because
there's a normal
like experiment yeah there's a normal
human curiosity
you know what i mean at first you're
trying to prove yourself wrong that that
didn't really happen
yeah but then you see that it did happen
so then you try to find out what the
limits are what are the boundaries of
this thing
then you're like can this thing [ __ ]
hurt you
and who because me and red talk about
the light you know can this [ __ ]
thing
can this hurt you and he's like and red
was like oh yeah look at him
this thing could just [ __ ] put
something over the door when you walk in
it could fall on you of course it could
hurt you
you know but it did it it could have
hurt and that was another thing that
read was like he's
red says well it hasn't hurt us so far
it can
so i guess it's not going to know what i
mean because
that's a reasonableness that's really
what we got down to
it's done all this [ __ ] it could kill us
but it hasn't
so it's probably not going to do you
think if it hated us that much it was
objects moving and just kind of
unexplained and as far as you
you're concerned it's a ghost and it's
interactive
and you feel the presence and [ __ ]
it's just a weird [ __ ] you've seen it
yeah
like i said in some ways there's a small
you saw the small amounts of the
yeah yeah you were freaked out though i
wasn't freaked out i thought it was like
really interesting okay
because you said you walked back there
and you thought that something was
watching you
yeah but it didn't i don't it's weird
but it didn't really scare me i guess
because
i figured it was just you you know what
i mean it's not like me it's a pool
no i know right but i'm just saying so i
didn't think it was like some a demon or
like a malevolent
you know what i mean so i wasn't like
afraid that it was gonna like some kind
of
some something in the unconscious can do
it
unless you got really mad at me one time
and like flung a blicket brick at my
head or something like that
that would be bad no i know i'm just
saying but you know but i
i in a i don't know i just thought it
was kind of neat because because i was
kind of like because i remember i told
you like all the time i was like man i
wish i'd seen that
you saw it it didn't scare me it just i
thought it was
it was like it was weird and it was like
really i was like whoa
it's that's what it's like it's the
thing that controls all the characters
in your dreams
okay yeah you're dreaming you're not in
total control of this dream there's
characters in this [ __ ] dream that do
[ __ ] against your will
but they still do it well who are those
characters
well they're you yeah well that's what
that poltergeist is
yeah but there are things in my dreams
that have [ __ ] me over
so that's one of the things that kind of
worries you you seem to always like
fight people in your dreams yeah
victor says animals and people ancient
aliens is still on
they somehow stretched it to 16 seasons
how do you stretch that how do they keep
coming up with [ __ ] does it still got
that same dude with the [ __ ] hair
well you can't have ancient aliens
without that guy
ancient aliens is a [ __ ] modern
marvel of editing
well it's the editing well like could it
be that aliens have come from afar to
see
us in the [ __ ] that's the thing any
time you see that
any time you see uh have aliens see a
headline
yeah or hear somebody like could it be
that blah blah blah question mark any
time you see a question mark the answer
is always no i always know
that that's a news headline i know
that's sort of the answer
they're just saying that because they
want to say something without saying it
definitively and without getting in
trouble
yeah so if it's a question the answer is
always now pretty much well it depends
on what the question is but you know
what i'm saying
could it be that spiders are descendants
of alien visitors
they're like yeah it could be maybe but
probably could it be the ancient aztecs
had a direct line to the alien gods
it's just gonna be [ __ ] like that that's
the thing
well [ __ ] like that i kind of feel like
maybe the reason why the paranormal
stuff has persisted or this type of
this whole subculture of ancient aliens
all that kind of stuff has persisted
is because a lot of that stuff is in so
nebulous an area that you can't
disprove it exactly or even if you did
they wouldn't believe it anyway but it's
like
it it's kind of just in this area it's
yes that could have happened
but the likelihood of it happening is
infinitesimally small
but that's still a legit question to ask
i guess you know what i mean so that's
kind of how they get around things like
that
i still can't believe they've done 16
seasons of ancient how the [ __ ] do you
come
how do you come up with 16 seasons
of shows okay so kudos to whoever is
writing and researching that [ __ ]
because you guys can come up with a lot
more [ __ ] than i can come up with
i don't think i could come up with that
much [ __ ] you know what i'm saying
to to fill that many seasons
i can't even believe that [ __ ] [ __ ]
like ghost adventures and stuff like
that has lasted as long as it did
because essentially all that show is
we're going to this creepy abandoned
place and we're going to walk around in
the dark and be like hey did you hear
that
yeah and have their little like evp
machines hey it sounded like somebody
said something
that's all they do nothing ever happens
the worst one
was uh paranormal u paranormal
university you heard that
i don't think i ever saw that one yeah
wait that was the thing
yeah and it was a series kind of like
taps it was kind of like response to
taps
it had this guy who um
evidently he said he saw something when
he was young but he never said what it
was that he saw
and they went out to all these [ __ ]
uh
places where they did investigations but
they were kind of haphazard
investigations
and in the end he what ended up
happening is that the show
started to get cancelled and somebody
they somehow raised
like forty or fifty thousand dollars for
him
to go to some kind of a convention i
don't remember all the details
and he just stole the money and [ __ ]
and [ __ ]
disappeared you heard that he was like
the host of the show he stole the body
and then he got fired from the show
because he stole the money
but i think the show was canceled anyway
and so he was like [ __ ] you guys yeah
and it turned out that the other dude
that was on the show with him was like
his boyfriend
he was gay but they never came out of
the closet behind it
and they asked him what he did with the
money and they said that they spent it
on anal bleaching that's what he said
anal bleaching all right that's a pretty
good answer yeah that's what he said
okay that's
that wasn't true well no i'm just like
kudos to that dude for coming up with a
funny
yeah what [ __ ] [ __ ] stupid is that
he had no bleaching is not that
expensive
what was [ __ ] funny is that the dude
[ __ ]
had a huge following from that show
okay and could have done really well
on the uh convention circuit
yes instead he stole the [ __ ] body
and you know he can't show his face
since that i don't know if you got you
got
some of you guys in the audience might
know the dude's name yeah i don't think
i've ever heard of that one i mean
there's so many different [ __ ]
paradigms that was that was must have
been around 2008 2009
2010 around that time
yeah i don't know i feel like a lot of
them are just kind of the same
you know it's like even if they say they
have a different angle or they say they
have a different thing it's like they
always just seem like
somebody's looking oh okay that's a
starry night
what starry night he's telling me hey
brother just check it in we're getting
ready to announce the show will's pub
oh yeah i was i was just wondering about
that earlier yeah he's asked me how the
nightlife's been it's been slow here
oh okay that's michael from the starry
night you guys
he um yeah they will want to play up
here
yeah they usually play at will's pub
which is like a really cool place that's
been there for [ __ ] ever
i thought they were going to play in
december but i guess that didn't get
canceled
yeah he wanted me to call him
don't call him right now i can't call
him well i mean you can but he'd have to
be on the ship
no there's a number there but that might
be old he might have asked michael
doesn't want to be on the show
see all these [ __ ] damn [ __ ] rock
bands calling me
all these rock stars
[Laughter]
and then i just [ __ ] show up to these
shows and a [ __ ] acts like you don't
[ __ ] know me
that's how they are
yeah and then like they're like i love
those guys the other ones are like oh
man
they're calling him over michael come
here man [ __ ] [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
you doing yeah
i'm just [ __ ] with you tom just [ __ ]
me i love michael yeah michael
i love everybody from the in it they're
like they're super nice guys that's
that was my favorite band i got those
[ __ ] signed
they're super awesome yeah man like
every time they play somewhere like me
and howard like talk about [ __ ]
horror movies like all the time because
he's super into like old horror movies
like i am
yeah so we always kind of get all into
that [ __ ] but um yeah somebody said okay
so tammy was saying because we were
talking about animals earlier
and she was telling tila my
mother-in-law told me one time
god made animals to live outside and she
believed that was where they belonged
and then she said i love my fur babies
and let them sleep with me
who the [ __ ] would ah
man that's some [ __ ] right there
pookie sleeps in bed with us
most of the time unless she like kind of
feels like [ __ ] it you guys are moving
your feet too much or something like
that then she'll go sleep in her little
hole in the cat tree
but other than that she almost always
like either sleeps on my feet or like
next to my hip
yeah pretty much all night so you guys
got any topics you want us to talk about
how long we've been streaming um not
even two hours not even two hours it's
like so
short still yeah but i'm still going bad
i kind of oh you know what somebody said
i think it was on
yesterday's stream they said here's
something that
we would like you guys to talk about on
tomorrow's stream
what are your favorite bad
movies somebody asked
that was okay one that was made to be
bad or one that would just happen to be
bad i mean it's
either i guess it either thing don't the
coffee pastor was pretty [ __ ]
good seriously it was made to be bad i
loved philosophy
so it just like warms the cockles of my
heart
that was pretty i was just like whoever
made this i love you guys
i want to hang out with them god damn it
zach said what's a story idea you've
always wanted to write
i have had oh my god you don't even know
i've had this [ __ ] novel idea
outlined for like [ __ ] three or four
years now
i have the whole i don't want to give
too much of it away i think i've read a
little bit of it on
or you know uh at least an early
iteration of it
like maybe on one of our special edition
like christmas shows or something like
there were halloween shows or something
like that like a year or two ago
and i had like all these images
and i was gonna do this story about
there was gonna be like these twins and
one of them was a psychic and then like
there was gonna be they moved to this
like move back to this little town and
it was like i was maybe gonna do
something with a witch or something like
that
i don't know but i've i've been like
kind of [ __ ] around with this idea
and i've written like some of it
but i haven't had time to get back to my
fiction which really bumped me out
but hopefully eventually i'll get back
to doing that
um bad movies you know what
you know what's weird like the first
thing i thought of was
and we might have talked about this
before i have a really
i have a real soft spot for the [ __ ]
um what's his name uh robert stigwood
he did the sergeant pepper's lonely
hearts club band movie i think it was
78 i want to say sergeant peppers was a
great movie the bee gees
alice cooper was in it aaron smith was
in it peter
brampton was going to ever just want to
just have [ __ ] fun objectively it's a
terrible movie
but it's not a movie i love it i love it
it's not a movie it's a great it's so
bad it's a greatest hits album
of [ __ ] old music a beatles song sung
by other people
yeah it's like it's a great it's a it's
a it's a beatles
tribute music video album that's what i
would call
sergeant pepper's it's kind of like yeah
it's there's a story but
it it's like a series of vignettes yeah
it doesn't matter the story doesn't
matter no not really yeah
and you're this is late 70s late 70s
right
i'm pretty sure it was 78. i think it
was 78.
so you're talking about before xanadu
these movies were [ __ ] pothead movies
you're supposed to just get
high as [ __ ] and go watch these [ __ ]
movies they were like
the substitute for a concert so the
audience was very different
um the scene back then was a lot
different i was a kid in california
during that time
it had been nine and i remember the mood
it was a very sexually charged air era
it was set it was a sexy era i mean
there was a lot of nudity and people you
go down
to the [ __ ] sierra nevada mountains
and [ __ ] a little kid and there's
teenage naked teenage girls walking with
a full bush full bush [ __ ]
smoking pop with the park rangers that
people act today
like [ __ ] morals have gone out the
window
no not really [ __ ] um
the 70s was [ __ ] far wilder than
today
far wilder than today and i'd imagine
the 63
at least in california um
but the difference was is that things
were very optimistic back then and
people were not
judgmental they weren't real preachy you
didn't really have
kind of like this kind of there's almost
kind of an old lady mentality in in the
united states nowadays it's weird
about what you can say what you can't do
everybody just did whatever the [ __ ]
they wanted
uh which sometimes led to trouble uh i
don't know well yeah like i said you
can't let everybody do what they want
whatever because some people
want to do really horrible [ __ ] it was a
[ __ ]
3d full life heavy metal magazine
if you saw a [ __ ] heavy metal like
tila saw heavy metal
that movie it was like that it just had
that flavor it was
a mixture of reality and fantasy um
and it wasn't just because i was a kid i
remember the adults the adults at least
in the california area were like that
and california was in those days was
ahead of the game and it was
set in the trends for the rest of the
country now the summers i go to
mississippi
see my dad later on after my parents got
divorced
and mississippi was nothing like that
but it was still cool
and they were pretty wild too it's just
a different
different way of manifesting it you know
what i mean [ __ ] it was because
it was not a prudish time it was never
prudish i don't think in the united
states i think that's
more mythical really than anything else
but um those movies made a lot more
sense when i saw santa do recently you
saw it with me
yeah i watched it i was taken back to
that mentality and i could see
how that movie would have really
appealed to me i've had that song stuck
in my head since
it was a good light entertainment movie
um another one from that time that
really made sense and it still makes
sense to me today i guess in the context
that
was greece greece won and greece ii
wasn't bad either but i still love
greece and honestly i unabashedly love
greece too
i know objectively it's not a great
movie but
i don't know there's something about it
there's something about it that i really
like
it's weird because i think that i liked
gree when i was younger i liked greece
too better than greece one because i saw
a grease tube before i saw greece one
actually this one's better
but as i get older yeah obviously grease
one is like way way better but i was
like a little kid when i first saw them
but grease too is actually like really
good now i did not see phantom of the
paradise
but watching that recently i could
retroactively see how i would have
really liked that one
um phantom of the paradise fits right in
there with those
except it had a lot more of a darker
element to it it was a lot more hard
rock
you know which i and prog rock and
[ __ ]
i really like that one um
i wish i had seen that back then yeah
there's a lot of movies i kind of wish
mango said that his favorite bad movie
was uh humanoids from the deep
yeah i remember that one that was that
we actually we just watched that not too
long ago now if you like the music ones
that we talked about there's another one
that's forgotten but you could probably
see it
probably see it for free on youtube i
looked at it again it was a trip but
it was the beginning of music videos
mtv just started and there was a dude
named michael nesmith and
he was from the monkeys wasn't he yeah
and he was he was drummer for the
monkeys i think
that's hard to say not only was he the
donald trump no i think mickey dolan was
the job yeah
[ __ ] he came out i still loved that show
when i was a kid he came out with an
entire video album that they played on
hbo
yeah yeah every now and then elephant
parts yeah yeah i remember that
and that there was being a kid
that i don't remember a whole lot about
how
how good the music was today the monkeys
did one called head too
but elephant parts i remembered
loving that as a kid it was it was very
very different
there's an entire album of video of
music videos
that's just the weirdest [ __ ] you know
and it had a lot of comedy in it
and it wasn't funny um i had to go back
and check that out
i wonder if you could get an hd version
of that oh i'm sure you're probably good
well
because nowadays i feel like god it's so
much easier to get [ __ ] nowadays
yeah it's like because even [ __ ] that
was kind of obscure when we were younger
it's not as obscure anymore well i feel
like it you know it became kind of a
cult classic so now like people that are
our age that now like
run all these independent businesses
that put these [ __ ] movies out
you know like shout factory and [ __ ]
arrow and whatever
and so it's like they're like hey we
need to get this [ __ ] movie oh
another one i would recommend too this
isn't a bad movie i don't think
but um did you guys see it's animated
did you guys see the movie rock and roll
it's canadian
it's animated familiar yeah right yes
well it's it's not rats but it's well
they are but they're kind of
it's like post-apocalyptic and like the
humans and rats have like evolved so now
like they're like rat humans but they're
still humans they just kind of look
a little bit rat like i remember it was
kind of like heavy metal yeah yeah it
was a little bit like that it had like
the same i think some of the same
animators worked on it yeah
and it was basically a story it had like
[ __ ] oh the music and it was so good
it was like it was blondie it was cheap
trick that was [ __ ] iggy popped and
some [ __ ] lou reed did some [ __ ] in it
it's so so good and i saw it like a
million times and
i think i think you can get it for free
on youtube
maybe no i watched it for free on
youtube but i don't know if it's there
anymore moving down and said
uh you know when my uncle was living in
san diego red who was you know in
in the book mammoth mountain my uncle
red one of his friends
was one of the illustrators and
cartoonists in heavy metal
in the magazine heavy metal i don't
remember his name
but i do remember that he brought some
story boards over
to show red what he was working on
and i can remember the scenes the
illustrations
and i believe it ended up in heavy metal
magazine maybe somebody out there might
be able to recognize it and then i would
know what artist it was but it was
one of red's friends and in the
storyboard it had some humanoid aliens
and they're flying a spaceship and when
they're speaking you know they have
little speech bubbles
in the speech bubbles was just a bunch
of symbols it was an alien language
you know what i mean you couldn't
understand what they were saying and
they were looking through a periscope
in the spaceship and zooming in on
another ship that was coming at them in
space and some stuff happened
and that's all i can kind of remember
they were they looked like men in weird
helmets and it kind of had spikes coming
out on the side it was kind of crooked
it was crazy
it looked a little kind of realistic
alex asked to see a french guy by any
chance
what was he a french guy no i don't know
i was i was i was only
about 12 or 13. i don't i think he was
from california
but um it was
the storyboards that i saw they were
they were incomplete
it was some of it was in pencil
but some of it had been inked in already
no color
but you know what i mean like yeah yeah
it was like he was still drawing it
yeah some of it was in color or
something not excuse me some of it was
in
ink most of it that what i saw i
remember it was like
three or four panels maybe four panels
and three of them were inked in and one
of them was maybe like half
inked in but it was just in black and
white no color
and i can remember
it i remember being blown away by the
illustrations
and red was telling me yeah he's in
heavy metal magazine
and i was just like oh okay but that was
before i had seen the movie yeah before
that didn't really make it
didn't make a bit it didn't make a an
impact on me at the time
but that was all the california scene
and i don't i don't know who that was
but i met the guy he was just like a and
what was funny he was probably like i
consider him to be like an old man like
he's old he was probably about 18 or 19.
isn't that funny you remember back then
i remember i distinctly remember this
still i was
in uh when i was in six right i was 12
years old it was 1984.
and i remember thinking to myself
wow in the year 2000 i'm going to be 28
years old
that's so old and now i'm 20 years older
than that
so you know speaking of animated movies
let me ask you guys i don't know if i
mentioned this before
have you guys seen the
jack and the beanstalk animated
thing it's from 1970.
i don't know mid mid 70s maybe i can't
remember what year it was from
and it was japanese but they were trying
to make it look more
western yeah i remember you tell me
about that and so it was dubbed into
english
now i saw this on cable when i was a kid
and i loved it because it was super
super weird and super
uncanny if you don't know what i'm
talking about it was like jack and the
beanstalk
but the giant was named
tulip he had um boxer shorts that had
hearts on him and stuff
but he also had his mother
who was this tiny little witchy woman
named madame hecuba
and she actually spoiler alert turned
out to be a
robot yeah um yeah so there was a whole
thing like jack goes up the thing and
like there's it's like a cloud city and
there was like this princess she had the
big eyes and everything like an anime
but i didn't know what anime was in
uh when i was a kid so i
well hi oh she wants to go outside oh
she wants to go outside i'm gonna put a
collar on her
okay yeah put her collar on and let her
go outside but um
[Music]
she comes in and she's like hey hey
it's like almost seven when can i go
outside it's dark i gotta go [ __ ]
oh i gotta like okay never mind i i i
gotta think of something
but um because i thought of something
that i have to mention later
but yeah so the so there was that whole
thing that was like the
the princess or whatever and she was
supposed to marry the giant
and i saw this like a bunch of times
when i was a kid on cable
and i was like man that's pretty cool
and it was like really weird and it was
like really like
unsettling and [ __ ] and then like i
didn't see it for a really long time
and so then for a long time i thought
maybe i'd imagined it because i
asked like people about it and they like
didn't know what the [ __ ] i was talking
about and they thought i was crazy
so i was like maybe i did imagine it i
don't know but then like a couple years
ago
i actually found it on youtube and i'm
like oh thank god
i'm not crazy this did actually exist
and that was when i found out that it
was actually japanese and it was dubbed
into english and that was like something
that
as i said it was made by a japanese
studio but they were trying to make it
like a disney movie so they're trying to
make it like more western
so you know they put like songs in it
and they try to make it look more like a
disney movie even though
looking at it now i can see like all the
japanese influences
at the time i didn't know so um
so if any of you guys have seen that let
me know because
i really really like that because
there's like a lot of really creepy
like [ __ ] [ __ ] in there what i was
gonna say
that i you know wanted to like put a pin
in and come back to
because when i was reminded of her when
i go outside
i was on my walk this morning because
remember i said yesterday that i didn't
walk yesterday because i was too [ __ ]
tired
i wasn't hungover i was just really
tired and then i was kind of like well
i'll just like i'll make it up tomorrow
so this morning i got up i walked five
miles
and then i was like you know what
instead of doing another three mile walk
later
i'm just gonna do it right now so i did
eight miles like all in one go
and then when i got back my feet were
hurt really bad but when i was out
i saw a big raccoon
and it just like ran across the path
except it was big it was big like an
adult but its tail was like
not full grown like it was kind of
so i don't know if it was like a
juvenile maybe like maybe it didn't get
all its fur out or whatever but
there's all kind of like [ __ ]
wildlife around here you know
um so did anybody see
like joe is that what you're talking
about it came out in japan in 1974 in
the us 1976
is that the one that is that what we're
talking about because
i kind of feel like for a long time i
thought i imagined it i wrote like a big
thing about it on my blog because
i was so happy that i found it again
because i thought it was a fever dream
tila says i want to watch squirm i would
recommend
well watch the mystery science theater
version because it's really funny but
the mystery science theater version i
think that cuts a lot of the gore out
because i think it's a lot gorier than
squirm is actually
not a terrible movie
as far as mst standards go my standards
are very low because like i said i grew
up watching mst so it's like i have a
lot of affection for even the worst
[ __ ] movies
the worst thing a movie can be from my
point of view
is boring yeah it's boring then that's
no i mean yeah it's like it can be
bad but as long as it's bad in an
entertaining way i don't give a [ __ ] if
it's bad
why do you think what do you think and
the dude who's [ __ ] oh my god i loved
bird
dude so who's always playing some kind
of jesus type figure that that weird oh
that guy yeah that weird guy
those movies uh are terrible but they're
fun to watch
especially with commentary you want you
want to see a rip tracks
version of that but a good bad movie
has to have one that has to have not
only does it have to
be a lot of fun
if it has a backstory that's even better
i would say the king of all
the bad movies that are still good is
technically not that bad
it's made bad by
the content and that would be blood
sport because that's supposed to be the
life of frank dukes
and frank duke's a [ __ ] [ __ ]
pathological liar he's a [ __ ] fake
martial artist
and some dude in hollywood heard this
dude's lies
i was like did that make a great movie
let's make a movie and they [ __ ] made
an action movie based on the [ __ ]
tall tale that frank dix dukes [ __ ]
told
so bloodsport
i saw it as a kid and didn't know it was
based on anything that was true
or supposed to be true at the very end
it says frank dooks and then how many
people he killed all these records and
[ __ ]
and how many victories and i was like
killed i was like wait a minute
that's based on a true story but
but you see the thing is when you're a
kid and you're teaching you believe
anything sure
and then there's a movie about it and
well then
and then at the end it was written that
there were records then [ __ ]
and that's like something out of the
guinness book of world records
that's fact yeah because you're not real
critical back then
yeah and i think a lot of people weren't
very critical back then
well it's not like now where you can
like just [ __ ] you can google things
and [ __ ] check
people people who are not very cr we're
not critical thinkers back in those days
well they're still not now but it's like
you know at least you don't have an
excuse nowadays
well today today the lying's a lot more
sophisticated
well it has to be it has to be but back
in those days
you could tell a [ __ ] just a bold
feeling it was much easier to [ __ ]
yeah and as long as it was just a bowl
of face line there was no way to check
on it
so you're you always kind of kind of had
to suspend your disbelief out of
courtesy
i guess you know maybe that dude is a
secret agent well i don't know
i'm not really sure how the [ __ ] cnn
works
i mean i saw pictures of him with night
vision goggles so maybe he is a [ __ ]
secret agent because it's not like just
any [ __ ] could buy them
through the mail or anything these
things are awfully expensive
just [ __ ] ridiculous [ __ ] but i'd
probably have to say bloodsport for me
that movie's funny is your favorite bad
movie yeah guys there's so many these
frank frank jokes
i'd like so many you know what i was
okay
[ __ ] it first here's what before you go
off
it has so bloodsport has so many
different elements
okay and one of the main elements see
zach zach my resident gay will tell you
the [ __ ] main thing is they got this
thread of homo eroticism going through
it
well that was kind of like a big thing
in the eight well all
80s action movies had that there's
something about
which is funny because nobody wanted to
acknowledge it there's somebody
claude van damme all right i don't know
if it had something to do with like
retro europe euro masculinity i don't
know
he was always half naked with
[ __ ] cheetahs and [ __ ] and [ __ ]
showing his ass and yeah
bodybuilders did that [ __ ] too it was
just something about van damme
bodybuilding in general has a homoerotic
content
you know just aspect to it you have to
admit that it really does
oh well wait you're going to say that
there's no gay men in [ __ ]
bodybuilding [ __ ] yeah there's a
bunch of no i didn't say that i'm just
saying it that it's always
had that yeah yeah it's always had that
and i feel like people don't like
acknowledge when you have
a [ __ ] when you have a situation
where it's a [ __ ] bunch of dudes
all right working out trying to perfect
masculine aesthetics great okay you're
gonna have some gay guys in there that's
just gonna happen
all right and that's it and arnold will
tell you that even back in the day
and and they didn't they weren't hung up
on that that didn't mean anything
it's kind of like that [ __ ] spartan
spartan man worship some of them guys
were [ __ ]
intelligent for more than one reason you
know
but that's just that's just gonna happen
you know
um victor says it's not gay if you keep
your socks on
but uh there's just some there's just
some
about van damme he's
obviously heterosexual but there's
something kind of bisexual about his
energy
that's and i wasn't the only one to
notice it well the thing is that's
probably like appealing to a wider
audience
i don't know what it is it's [ __ ]
weird but it's in that movie too i mean
there's a scene where
this asian guy who's his master who's
got him tied up and doing [ __ ] like
extension torture and [ __ ] trying to
spread his legs way
far apart beyond his [ __ ] you know
all this [ __ ]
it's bondage it's a [ __ ] body yeah
what's going on
and then later on he's [ __ ] fighting
with these other [ __ ] dudes and keeps
punching them in the [ __ ] balls
there's this
i don't care about your balls my balls
are stronger than your balls
is this what i don't [ __ ] know what
it is man my balls are stronger than
your ball
but you know well the thing that cracks
me up about
because i feel like in the 1980s i don't
know if everyone was just clueless or
what but it just seemed like
in the 1980s you had this mainstream
action movie thread like running through
it
where everything was like hyper
masculine or like hyper
you know oh we're all badasses and
everything but when you watch them now
they're very very clearly
uh you know i won't even say gay subtext
because it wasn't even
subtext it was like really really
obvious
and it seems like really obvious to us
nowadays but i guess
in the 80s everyone was just like
pretending that it wasn't
yeah i don't know which what and i was
gonna say too that
one of the things that is most hilarious
to me is that
when they started because you know
they've had like playboy forever
and then they start a play girl
ostensibly i don't know if this is
really what they thought would happen
ostensibly because oh we want the ladies
to want something to look at too
so we're going to have like playgirl
magazine which has all these like naked
buff dudes in it
and not really many women
bought that magazine it was almost all
gay men so i was like what did you think
was gonna
happen women don't buy that kind of [ __ ]
no we know about it
and it's like it is funny to me that
they didn't realize that at the time
it's like that's just asking if i'd seen
a lot of heroes no i haven't seen it
i haven't seen it man um
uh rucker howard okay we have to see
that then
all right oh it's got rucker however in
it yeah okay
i don't think i've seen that either in
that one i mean i might have but i might
have forgotten i write a letter
didn't didn't um van damme come out as
bisexual uh i don't know if he did i
don't know anything about it
yeah did he i don't know either but
there was something even back in the day
i was like i think that is gay or
bisexual i was thinking that at the time
there was just
something about him
some of it was some about like the it
wasn't so much the movies it was like a
lot of his uh
uh promotional shots like you'd see him
on the covers of karate magazines and
stuff
and it was just kind of like shirtless
[ __ ] caressing
[ __ ] baby cheetahs
and [ __ ] hands my hands are funny
him in a [ __ ] g [ __ ] silk g-string
doing the splits above
some [ __ ] flowers or something and
him in a [ __ ] car [ __ ] with his
leg up over the [ __ ] it's just
[ __ ] weird you know i mean it's like
it was it was a european thing or it was
a gay thing sorry people i don't know
what it is i don't know if it was
european if it was bi or what
it just it didn't have the [ __ ]
feeling of [ __ ] bro science that a
lot that the americans well the thing
about it is that
things like that yeah maybe would appeal
more to women
than really like i wasn't sure
i thought maybe he was trying to be
sophisticated
yeah and that the american guys were
supposed to be just kind of like
luddites
you know he's trying to show off you you
try to show that he was different than
[ __ ] arnold
and different from stallone those guys
were just meat heads
he's fashionable maybe
okay so i'm going to say too that like i
don't know and
obviously i can't speak for everybody
like i'm a girl but i'm not going to
speak for
oh you know all other women everywhere
obviously because i'm just me
but there is something to be said i
don't like the bodybuilding thing at all
i'm not really into all that and i was
never really into that
i like you know when i was growing up
i was more into you're kind of more into
ambiguity or you're more into like i
like like
[ __ ] duran duran i liked all these
where they didn't really look like all
buff or masculine they looked kind of
feminine i guess you would say
but not overtly you know what i'm saying
it's kind of like you kind of were into
more into that because it was like more
mysterious it was like sexier
like i didn't really like especially
especially in the 80s i didn't really
like
the whole like oh i have all this big
mess
i didn't really like that it's like i
just thought that was like stupid
and yeah that wasn't like sexy to me it
was just kind of like eh
that dude's gonna be a dick i'm not
really into it i was just wasn't into
the thing about the 80s is that
it was very easy to confuse movie
stereotypes with reality
there was a certain kind of movie
stereotype
that they wanted to have in movies it
was a california thing
a [ __ ] muscle guy who is a [ __ ]
kind of like a dick
and he was with usually like a porn
star-type chick
yeah but i knew some people like that in
real life so they're not wasn't like
it wasn't like well no i did know some
people like that in real life so
it wasn't like this but the people that
were doing this on the movies
a lot of times we're well known people
that's not how they work
yeah a lot of them were well known
bodybuilders are well known actresses
and
that's not how they actually were they
were playing a role in the movie
when i was in high school especially in
the michigan area era
you had young guys on all kinds of
anabolic [ __ ] steroids
working out they got [ __ ] huge quick
well they were dicks not because they
were working out they were [ __ ]
dicks because they were [ __ ] on
anabolic steroids they had [ __ ] roid
rage
they're [ __ ] nuts so
there's like something to that well a
woman that doesn't really matter it's
like well
you're just being a dick and that's like
the end product yeah so i'm not really
you're kind of like writing yourself
into that story they didn't care about
women
well obviously you just didn't you know
i remember
and alex says isn't it like that
horseshoe effect you go so far in one
direction you end up curving back around
toward the opposite end
so being super macho ends up being
curving back toward the feminine exactly
and that's actually
well no that's what i was going to say
it's like it's it's kind of like a
circle
more than like a thing you know what i
mean it's like a circle you end up being
like so macho so much in sumacho and
then
you become like kind of girly and it you
kind of saw it too
in the sort of 80s
power metal type of thing where it was
kind of like
we're making this super macho music but
they looked like
ugly drag queens yeah but you know
okay now and we're going back into this
cultural thing all right
what was metal it depended on what year
you were talking about
and what band you were talking about
metal eventually got to where
british metal was like jews priest and
[ __ ] iron maiden it was very
simplistic la got a hold of that [ __ ]
and it [ __ ]
glammed it mixed with [ __ ] glass well
and like i said glam was very i mean
look at like the new york dolls which
are the progress with
partial drag yeah honestly they they
would come on and drag
so you know kind of like the [ __ ]
beginning of all this [ __ ] would have
been
motley crue all right and if you looked
at motley crue who those dudes were if
they were
basically from the [ __ ] ghetto
they didn't have any money hung out with
a bunch of [ __ ]
strippers and [ __ ] people just got
high
they had a lot of girlfriends they stole
their girlfriend's clothes
their girlfriends did their makeup and
their hair they looked like [ __ ]
chicks
they weren't real physically fit or
anything these were not the same dudes
who were [ __ ] taking steroids in the
damn [ __ ] gold gym there's a totally
different scene
all right they they so i would never
really call those dudes like macho
they were guys like [ __ ] uh we know
people like in the scene they weren't
now
yeah like uh
just like every other [ __ ] musician
in the industrial scene they were like
that
like uh what was what's a big tall
skinny guy look just like that
um broke up with his girlfriend now
you know what i'm talking about narrow
it down
broke up with his baby's mama went out
and stripper and
and they left her there was a threesome
going on for a while then they dumped it
damien you don't now you said his name
that's his name but yeah that guy
well you asked me to they were like
damian they were like they were like
they were guys like him
that's that's who you're dealing with
and so it's not i wouldn't
if you look at damon damien is a good
guy but he's not [ __ ] ultra macho at
all
yeah but i just wouldn't like him i just
well
well that's the thing i think that
people don't [ __ ] about being tall
and another thing that a lot of dudes
understand because you know
by and large this culture is so run by
dudes
one thing that dudes don't understand is
that women are not
we're very complex um
we we don't have like i don't even
really have a one thing that i like
it's kind of like i don't know man it's
kind of like what your energy is
i don't i don't have a type you know
what i'm saying yeah
so it's really hard for me like when
people say oh i have this type it's not
in the other i'm just like i don't
i don't have that but those gym rats
that were [ __ ] huge that were famous
in the 80s they all [ __ ] came out of
that scene there in california around
venice beach a lot of them
and that scene really didn't have a
whole lot of women
uh it wasn't really a whole lot about
women you did have some females that
hung out there that would because i've
heard them all tell the stories that
time it's still kind of like that now
not as bad as it was it's not as popular
as it was
uh they had groupies and stuff you know
what i mean that were into that kind of
guy
but for the most part those dudes were
not doing that for for
for women they were actually doing it
for men in a way
it wasn't it wasn't sexual though it was
like a competition it's like dudes dr
drag racing cars who had the fastest car
but they were just doing these
modifications to themselves some of them
were gay but most of them weren't
zack said wasn't androgyny kind of sexy
and trendy in the 80s it absolutely was
i think that was kind of a big thing in
the 80s androgyny well that went all the
way into the 90s in the [ __ ]
goth scene i could show you [ __ ]
issues of propaganda magazine with some
of the [ __ ]
most [ __ ] famous [ __ ] goth dudes
of the 90s like oh what's his name from
[ __ ]
uh [ __ ] what is his name
oh man it was tonya's ex-boyfriend
who voltaire no she married him
it's the other one
who else she had the white hair the
white spiky hair is real skinny
um you gotta narrow it down you gotta
narrow it down
i mean [ __ ] was a legend every
[ __ ] girl was the end of that dude
from that time but that's what i mean
and especially like i i feel like in the
80s and particularly in the
goth scene in the 80s androgyny
in the 80s very very big and
i was into it and i think the goth scene
was like
even more that you know what i mean
i feel like the 80s was the first time
that that
kind of thing had gone mainstream where
you could kind of like be sexy being
androgynous because i still remember
in the early early to mid 80s and being
me being like
yeah i know exactly what you're talking
about yeah john koviak
he was one of the propaganda's most
famous models yeah that dude
super super hot yeah that was super hot
that was tonya's ex-boyfriend
oh [ __ ] i didn't know she went out with
oh okay yeah i had picture well i
you know what okay one of my very early
novels
i used that dude as like a model
because sometimes you have like pictures
of it you're like you so you can
describe the person and like you can
picture them
i used him as like a model for one of my
characters
in one of my very very early novels
she's just as funny as that [ __ ]
she knows i've been around and all these
people but she doesn't know that i knew
that
it was that that deep no yeah it was
that dean well i knew that she had dated
voltaire
yeah i knew she went yeah yeah but her
like ex before him was john kovacic
okay so yeah i didn't know that because
i knew that you know i knew who that
dude was yeah
he was in propaganda i used to get every
issue of that okay i'm gonna show that
dude
let's find a picture of that if you're
listening to the audio i'm sorry that
you can't see all this stuff but you
know
what are you gonna do i'm gonna try to
[ __ ] full screen a damn picture i
mean you have to sit like when i was in
high school
like the dude that i was super in love
with
was like robert smith but like a hundred
times hotter
he had like the big [ __ ]
the big haystack black hair the eyeliner
we had like this awesome like [ __ ]
jawline
beautiful him and like this other guy
that worked at oh man there was this
dude i can't remember his name now
yeah yeah look at that that was john
koviak
yeah although i knew he had like white
hair later
yeah i was more familiar with the way
with the white hair
but it was like yes let me show you give
these girls a feast
yeah i'd do it yeah and tanya was
[ __ ] gorgeous
[ __ ] gorgeous she was my best friend
in boston
[ __ ] girl i mean
yeah there was like okay so yeah so like
i said in high school i was like super
into like this dude
where yeah
see there you oh my god look at that
see i like that that was back when they
used to dress in all this [ __ ] german
clothing well when they
used to look good yeah back in those
days and um
yes it was that guy and then there was
this other dude
this is hilarious you guys but there's
another one of john
yeah see see he's kind of famous
he was in i've never seen that picture
but i've seen like i have a bunch of
other pictures in propaganda
because like i said i had a bunch of
pictures of him for reference because i
used him as like a character reference
for one of my really earned it i didn't
find a picture of tanya and they'll
understand why it gets so bright in here
all of a sudden you're [ __ ] up my
focus
yeah look look at like all brightened up
i don't know what happened but yeah so i
was gonna say
you know that guy that was in high
school and there was this other dude
and he you guys are gonna laugh he
worked at
uh [ __ ] i don't know if this was a chain
but it was like a german restaurant
in a mall mr dunderbox he worked at a mr
dunder box
in the mall in daytona and he was like i
walked past there one day i was in the
mall
like this back in the 80s and i was like
what
and i like turned around and saw it he
looked just like he was like this big
tall
skinny and he had like this beautiful
[ __ ] face and he's like had the big
robert smith hair
like the [ __ ] teased black and i was
just like oh my god
i'm in love and uh my cousin knew him
and so she told him of course
that i was into him that i'd seen him
and he drew me something on a napkin i
might still have it somewhere i don't
know
it's probably up in the attic somewhere
but yeah so
all right i found a picture i told you
but it's not a good picture if i have a
type that's kind of my type
that was tanya but that's not a really
good picture of her really yeah
i can't see anything i can't see a nose
she doesn't have a nose
[Laughter]
she might have some [ __ ] public on
facebook
go ahead keep talking yeah zach says i
always thought that was ironic since the
80s were also so homophobic with the
aids crisis and satanic panic
yeah it's really weird because
i remember very
being into all this like new wave [ __ ]
on you know on mtv and stuff like that
in the 80s and everything was
you know like you know [ __ ] boy
george and adam ants and prince and all
that kind of stuff
and duran duran and i was like all into
that and that was kind of like the era
of
dudes kind of not being afraid to look
quote unquote feminine which whatever
the [ __ ] that means but the thing is
it is not mainstream well no but i mean
it
maybe not but it was kind of like more
mainstream than it had been
i suppose yeah and i still remember
not so much my parents but my granddad
in particular
i remember him just saying like oh
they're all gay
or you know you know using worse words
than that
but he would oh was it who's got an
earring on
oh he's got like [ __ ] eyeliner on
it's like hilarious that's a reasonable
picture of tonya but that's
that's new that's not how she looked
back that's not how she that's not how
she looked back then though
she was like back there yeah i hope we
don't get in trouble showing all these
people's pictures yeah
why is it so bright in here look at what
you did what'd you do stop right it's in
your mind
i i really don't think it is you know it
seemed like a bright dose yeah yeah
but yeah so that's the thing it's like i
just remember
all of this kind of like oh everyone's
[ __ ]
you know what i mean no you don't
remember that no
[ __ ] maybe it's just because i grew up
in florida yeah i don't know
and it's the [ __ ] south i just
remember everybody
in mississippi they didn't say that
maybe nobody you knew did but yeah i
knew a lot of people that
i mean you know what kind of people
you're talking about
your family my family people at my
school
all right yeah all that kind of [ __ ] no
yeah everyone was like and the thing
about it too when i was in junior high
and this was mid to late 80s
i was in junior high so i was like
really into new wave and there was like
a little contingent of people that were
into new wave you know like there's you
know
we were into like duran duran and
adamant and stuff and like kind of
postponk
and so it was kind of us
versus the heavy metal people who
ironically
the heavy metal people were always
getting on us
like you know all these [ __ ]
homophobic slurs and [ __ ] like that
but they were listening to like [ __ ]
hair metal which if you want to say
like those people look more like women
than
i mean if you want to go at it from that
angle they look more like women than
like new wave people did
i guess which i always which even back
then i thought was like very funny and
like hypocritical
i guess that was just where you were in
florida because in mississippi i'd even
have that experience
when i was in mississippi most of the
kids my age in that area
all [ __ ] look like something out of
[ __ ] um
it's like a new wave band no here it was
very
um well in daytona where i grew up
there was a very very small it was a
very small
contingent okay the rest of the people
were either bros
like jocks and then they would just beat
you up whatever or
people that were into heavy metal and
they would also beat you up
no [ __ ] i even in laurel mississippi
all the middle class kids are all kind
of like something out of violent films
or some [ __ ] like that you know they
were listening yeah
i did not have that oh you're a [ __ ]
kid kids that lived out in the country
there i guess you'd call them rednecks
and everything they just [ __ ] had
mullets and were listening to [ __ ]
judas priest and [ __ ] molly hatchet
and [ __ ] like that i didn't know they
wore camouflage but there wasn't any
kind of a
any kind of problem between them too
rural which is weird
yeah and i mean in daytona you really
got the sense
that there were essentially there were
three groups like i said
it was kind of like your new wave your
punk post punk kid [ __ ] oh no no no no
i lost it i lost it
oh [ __ ] well let me go pee and then i'll
restart it
actually looks like it's uh back
can you guys hear me is it back on
because uh i can see it here
but i don't see it clicking on that
laptop on that laptop it's frozen
so the laptop we're streaming off of the
[ __ ] the image is frozen
okay look it's back it's back okay good
good it's bad okay good
jenny went ahead and went to the
restroom just uh so we'll just we'll
just let it continue to run it just kind
of froze up
back in a second yeah i don't really
know what she's talking about that's
that was her experience that was florida
it was a long time ago
um and maybe it's because the population
density was a little bit higher around
here so they could [ __ ] enter into
kind of like tribal warfare
or something but in the real rural parts
and like in mississippi
nobody gave a [ __ ] what you look like
and we had
this effect on we had um we had mtv
and we had cables no it's not on yeah i
can say it right there they can hear me
did you move it i didn't get anything i
got nothing
i froze up okay
they're saying it started to stutter
yeah it froze up
okay should i restart wait it might come
back
maybe come on you can do it
they're saying it's working for them
well that was that last one
yeah but how long ago was that okay
we're gonna restart it
we'll put that i can't hear you
god [ __ ] damn it
we don't usually have this they said
they can hear it but um the
uh the visual the feed is frozen yeah
it's frozen on my [ __ ] too i can't yeah
i can't move anything
that's weird that's where they can hear
us
it looks like it's back yeah but well no
youtube's not
it's not no i'm just getting black
and then it keeps like freezing up all
right we're gonna [ __ ] open another
stream
hold on hold on i gotta restart
everything yeah
uh if i can oh my god this is so
frustrating why won't anything work
just work all right she's you know what
[ __ ] off